Oh, jetzt hab ich die Tasse versehentlich gedrückt. Aber jetzt hab ich die anderen auch gedrückt. Und, ja, das heißt...
Das sind wir schon, ab der ersten Sekunde Out of Sync.
Ja, und schon sind wir Out of Sync.
Hallo willkommen zu Mobile Max, Ausgabe Nummer 38 in ungewohnt kleiner Besetzung.
Hallo, ich bin Max.
Und ich bin Dennis.
Genau, wir brauchen hier so ein Sockpuppet, irgendwie so ein Bauchredner Dennis.
Dennis, im Geiste bist du bei uns. Das ist doch schön, oder? Aber so heute nur mit Tim und Max in einer klassischen Besetzung sozusagen. Und wir haben uns alle Mühe gegeben, hier wieder ganz großartige Dinge von uns zu geben und ein bisschen über Sachen zu diskutieren. Jetzt fehlt uns natürlich wieder gut 50% unseres Kompetenzstammens. Den müssen wir sozusagen jetzt einfach ausdenken. Stimmt's, Maxe?
Spontan erfinden, ja. Muss man uns heute mal richtig konzentrieren.
Hast du das mit der Kapitel-Taste, mit der Kapitel-Handbewegung, das hast du jetzt im Sinn, ja? Du weißt, neues Thema. Und dann machst du mir das C. Ihr könnt das jetzt nicht sehen. Max macht so eine...
Extrem coole.
Ja, Walk like an Egyptian-Bewegung. Geht dabei auch so leicht in die Knie, so mit so einer wippenden Bewegung im Schritt. Sieht einfach extrem Travolta-mäßig aus.
Weil eigentlich machen wir die Sendung gar nicht beim Sitzen, sondern auf der Tragfläche eines Flugzeugs.
Genau, nach dem Piloten-Check, in dem wir ja am Anfang schon durchgehen müssen, ist das so. Ja, genau. Ich muss jetzt mal schauen, ob ich es immer schaffe, meine Wundertaste zu drücken. Aber so Kapitelmarken-Ansagen ist irgendwie lame, oder? Also ich darf das nicht sagen, das muss lautlos gehen, oder? Oder soll ich immer so was sagen wie neues Thema? Das könnt ihr übrigens machen. Ich meine, wenn ich auf die Tasse drauf drücke, könnte ich theoretisch, habe ich jetzt nicht konfiguriert, weil... Ist doof. Ja, die Zeit hat dafür nicht gereicht, aber auf die Idee bin ich schon gekommen. Ich schicke ja ein MIDI-Signal, nehme das auf. Aber ich mache das nur, um sozusagen lautlos einfach den Zeitpunkt zu markieren.
Also das heißt, quasi frei programmierbare Tasten?
Genau. Das ist ja das, was man eigentlich will im Leben. Freiprogrammierbare Tasten. Und die eine freiprogrammierbare Tasse habe ich mir so freiprogrammiert, dass sie halt einfach eine MIDI-Note…
Wenn eine Fee zu mir kommen würde und sagen würde… Was wünschst du dir? Würde ich sagen, drei programmierbare Tassen?
Noch mal. Drei freiprogrammierbare Tassen.
Genau, genau das. So, und wenn ich die halt jetzt drücke, dann soll angeblich, hat mein Programm mir gesagt… Soll da was passieren? Dann nimmt er das hier sozusagen auf. Eine habe ich jetzt schon mal hier…
Fangen sie jetzt schon auf den Tief von Tim Prittler. Mist, die Tassen sind nicht aufgescheitert worden.
Ja, ich gucke gerade mal, ob er die andere irgendwie aufgescheitert hat. Tatsächlich, da ist so eine kleine Marke. Jaja, du Marke. Ich kann sie auch besser sehen, wenn ich sie länger gedrückt halte. Das ist vielleicht auch gar nicht so schlecht. So, und wenn ich die jetzt sozusagen drücke, dann müssen wir uns dann auch um ein anderes Thema kümmern.
Ach so, jetzt kommt das nächste Thema.
Genau, dieses Kapitel hieß jetzt die Einleitung. Begrüßung, was würdest du sagen? Wie nennt man das? Willkommen, Einleitung, Begrüßung, bla bla.
Eigentlich ist das ja schon die erste Studio-Fortschritte und Kapitel-Kram.
Stimmt. Da geht's schon dahin. Na ja, wie auch immer.
Den dritten Punkt hab ich schon vier Teil abgearbeitet.
Dann können wir ja sozusagen jetzt auf den ersten Punkt gehen, oder? Okay, gut, dann.
Oh, was geht denn da nicht?
Da gehen wir jetzt auf den... Oh ja, das ist wirklich ein bisschen Casper, der Theater. Ja, es gab diverse Verbesserungen hier. Es gibt jetzt Internet in diesem Studio.
Wir haben funktionierendes... Also, hab ich mir sagen lassen.
Ja, wie gut es funktioniert, muss ich noch zeigen lassen. Es ist definitiv besser als diese wackelige WLAN-Verbindung quer über die Straße, die ich vorher hatte. Aber soweit geht's ganz gut. Ich hab auch mal wieder hier Alice Comfort bestellt und mir... Würdest du bitte nicht dieses iPod-Kabel kurz schließen irgendwie mit deinen feuchten Händen? Ich hab natürlich auch feste IP-Adresse beantragt, wie das hier so bei Alice Comfort ja angeboten wird und dann auch durchgeführt wird und das sogar kostenlos. Aber ich weiß noch nicht, ob es schon erfolgt ist. Ich glaube, es ist noch nicht erfolgt. Meiner aus dem Augenwinkel heute einen Disconnect gesehen zu haben, hat aber jetzt keine Zeit, mich da drum zu kümmern. Aber danach finden ja die Disconnects auf Layer 2 statt und dann ist das halt nicht mehr so dramatisch. Das heißt, dein PPP baut sich nicht ab, du kriegst keine neue IP-Adresse. Und selbst wenn es sich abbauen würde, dann kriegst du dieselbe.
Was hast du denn jetzt hier für Technik eigentlich da, so DSL-mäßig? Immer noch alles auf der Basis?
Nee, was ganz Schlimmes, weil ich wollte ja auch erst mal warten, bis das da ist und mal gucken, was die mir liefern. Geliefert haben sie mir so eine Alice DSL-Box. Oh weia, ist das eine Sparnummer.
Sind das diese Zechsel-Dinger?
Ich weiß nicht genau, was das ist. Also da steht überall Alice drauf und das Ding meldet sich irgendwie mit Alice. Ich hab's nicht auseinandergeschraubt. Das ist so richtig blöden Internet. Da kannst du so fast überhaupt nichts mehr konfigurieren, was ich ja nachvollziehen kann. Keep it simple und so. Und die meisten brauchen nicht mehr. Das geht dann aber auch so weit, dass du zum Beispiel keinen DNS-Server mehr konfigurieren kannst. Was man ja vielleicht meinen sollte, eigentlich kein Problem ist. Aber bei Alice ist das definitiv ein Problem, weil die Jungs machen ja DNS-Hajacking.
Ach, die machen dieses, dass du kriegst keine?
Wenn du halt keine Antwort kriegst von deinem Nameserver, dann fangen sie sozusagen das ab, wofür wirklich mal geprügelt worden ist.
Ja, zurecht.
Zurecht geprügelt worden ist. Und was jetzt aber so ein bisschen Usus ist. Und dann präsentieren sie dir halt eine, unsere Tittenlady hat deine Adresse nicht gefunden, Seite und so. Das heißt, sie gehen ja einfach mal da so richtig schön ins Protokoll. Das geht natürlich gar nicht. Also wollte ich halt feste Nameserver, denen ich vertraue, einstellen. Aber dann nicht. Kann man sozusagen bei diesem Gerät nicht machen. Jetzt hätte ich natürlich eben mal eine AirPod Express ranhängen können. Nur, dass halt diese AirPod Express nach wie vor keine DSL-Modems haben. Was ich ja verstehen kann, weil das ist ja ein Moving Target. So eine Fritzbox und so weiter, die ja vor allem für den deutschen Markt ist, die haben das ja mit drin. Und dieses Gerät von Alice hat das halt auch mit drin. Aber weil es das eben mit drin hat und nicht nur als Modem betrieben werden kann, zumindest wüsste ich jetzt nicht wie, muss ich mir jetzt erstmal ein DSL-Modem organisieren. Also was weiß ich, eBay, irgendwelche Reste, oder mal rumfragen, ob noch jemand was hat.
Ich glaube, ich hab noch eins im Schrank liegen, falls ich das nicht entsorgt habe.
Siehst du mal, sowas kann ja immer... Ich dachte eigentlich auch noch, dass ich eins noch im Schrank liegen hab, aber bisher habe ich den Schrank nicht gefunden.
Die haben auch eine Halbwertzeit. Die gehen gerne mal flöten, habe ich festgestellt.
Flöten im Sinne von kaputt? Ja, klar, ich meine, das ist Elektronik, die geht immer kaputt.
Ja, aber auch wenn sie einfach so, hey, das habe ich da ausgebaut und das hat immer funktioniert, probier mal, geht nicht mehr.
Ja, das ist auch Wegwerf-Fahrer. Also ich meine, das ist kein High-End-Markt.
Die ersten, die so monströs groß waren, noch diese DSL-Modems, da dachte man noch, da steckt eine halbe Dampfverschiene hinter und die sind für die Ewigkeit gebaut.
Das waren die ja auch. Früher war ja alles besser, wie du weißt, und heute ist alles nur noch Plastischeiße. Gerade in diesem DSL-Markt und auch was die Anbieter betrifft. Gerade als ich das ja bestellte, ich weiß nicht, ob ich das schon erwähnt hatte, kam ja alles jetzt auch mit dem VDSL-Angebot raus und ich dachte mir so, oho, aha, 10 Megabit Upload und so weiter, toll, toll, toll. Hab da gleich angerufen und gucke auf die Webseite und dann hier auch irgendwie gibt's in Komfort. Da dachte ich mir so, super, ja damit, einmal dann bitte. Und? Na ja, dann hab ich dann irgendwie schon den ganzen Prozess mit, wie kann ich jetzt meinen aktuellen Vertrag stornieren und durch einen anderen ersetzen, also meinen sozusagen noch nicht ausgeführten Anschluss-Antrag. Und dann hab ich ganz am Ende nochmal nachgefragt, aber es ist schon irgendwie mit eigener IP-Adresse und so weiter. Ja nee, ach nee, das haben wir da nicht.
Ach, fester IP-Adresse geht da nicht mehr?
Nee, weil sie natürlich nur Telekom Resale machen und deren Kram machen. Das heißt, sie bei VDSL, also das hat er so nicht gesagt, das ist jetzt meine freie Interpretation, weil sonst könnten sie es ja ohne Mühen genauso machen wie bei ihren DSL-Anschlüssen. Aber das findet halt nicht statt und daraus lese ich, dass sie jetzt, um überhaupt erstmal im Markt zu sein, um überhaupt einfach mitzumachen, dass sie deswegen eben das nicht anbieten können. Obwohl es zu dem Zeitpunkt auf ihrer Webseite stand. Auch geil. Zum Thema Marketing und Realitätsverbindung. Also hab ich das alles nicht gemacht. Jetzt warte ich erstmal, zahle dann vielleicht später einfach die entsprechende Strafgebühr da zu wechseln, wenn sie da einen ordentlichen Service machen können. Weil da will ich jetzt erstmal hören, wie die Leute, was sie da zu bieten haben.
Ich sollte ja theoretisch in knapp einer Woche die VDSL bekommen. Bin ich ja mal sehr gespannt drauf, wie das alles so wird.
Ja, was ich auch noch nicht habe, ist mein i7-Mac. Alle anderen Kinder haben schon einen.
Nur ich nicht.
Das ist echt gemein.
Das ist wirklich gemein.
Obwohl mein Händler mir da hochunterhaltlich zugesagt hat, und das weiß ich auch, dass er das tun wird, dass ich irgendwie der erste bin, der einen kriegt, wenn er einen hat. Aber er hat halt noch keinen. Also iMacs, aber er hat halt keinen Quadcore-Mac. Und die Quadcore-Macs machen sich ja in den Benchmarks ganz ordentlich. Ich weiß nicht, ob du das mal gesehen hast. Es gab da sehr viele Benchmarks und man konnte denen nicht unbedingt so durchgehend Glauben schenken.
Aber was ich so rausgehört habe, wer jetzt noch einen Mac Pro kauft, ist dämlich.
Na ja, gut, wenn du einen Mac Pro kaufst, dann hast du andere Anforderungen, die ein iMac unter Umständen nicht erfüllt. Aber wenn es dir nur um Performance geht, dann bist du mit einem iMac durchaus bedient. Aber du kannst halt nach wie vor keine Karten reinstecken und die Platten nicht so leicht wechseln. Du kannst da keinen RAID drin betreiben und Pipapo. Also wenn du einen Profikomputer haben willst, dann kommst du am Mac Pro nicht dran vorbei. Ich denke mal, wir werden Anfang des Jahres dann auch relativ zügig ein Mac Pro Update sehen, wo dann halt diese neue Prozessor-Architektur auch drin ist.
Weil es dringt fällig dann einfach.
Na klar, ich meine, das muss Apple sicherlich nicht erklären.
Ja, vielleicht schon.
Da fragt sich, womit sie dann kommen. Also das riecht ja schon so ein bisschen nach Chor-Verdopplung und was nicht alles. Tja, das ist sozusagen mein persönliches Elend. Ja, und auf dem Markt hat sich auch einiges getan.
Oh Gott, wir müssen uns unbedingt irgendwie andere Übergänge zunehmen.
Ja, es ist irgendwie alles Google. Guck dir das an, was da auf unserer Geheimliste steht, wo wir langsam den Schleier vonlüften werden. Hast du dir diese Videos gegeben mit ChromiumOS?
Ich hab's sogar mal auf meinem MSI-Wind installiert, also auf einem Stick. WLAN geht noch nicht.
Hast du dieses Torrent-File da, was irgendwie über TechCrunch oder so rumging, hast du das genommen?
Genau, Leo vom FSDK-Log hat das irgendwie getwittert. Und da hab ich das mal ausprobiert, hab's wegen erhöhter Dämlichkeit zweimal nicht geschafft, das Ganze auf dem Stick zu kopieren. Weil man muss da per DD, heißt der Befehl, irgendwie so Disc, keine Ahnung was, also auf dem Terminal muss man das Image auf dem Stick kopieren und muss da bei dem BSD-Namen des Volumes angeben, beziehungsweise nicht das Volume, sondern das Gerät an sich. Und dann wird es rüberkopiert auf den Stick und dann hast du einen bootbaren Stick, solange man nicht den falschen Volumen-Namen angibt, so wie ich das getan habe. Was hast du denn für einen Volumen-Namen? Ich hab quasi den Namen der Partition angegeben. Also es gibt das Device, das heißt dann Disc2 zum Beispiel, und dann gibt es da einzelne Partitionen, da heißt es dann Disc2S1. Und das ist falsch?
Das hab ich auch gemacht. Was muss man machen?
Nur Disc2.
Ach so, weil das sozusagen die Partitionen mitschreibt?
Genau.
Und dann steckt das alles korrekt drin. Und danach, nachdem ich das dann dreimal probiert hatte, und es nicht klappte, hab ich es dann irgendwann mit dem richtigen Namen probiert, und hat's geklappt, also nachdem ich das dann gesehen habe. Und danach hat man ein extrem schnell budendes Betriebssystem, wie sich das so gehört.
Ist das auch diese sieben Sekunden, die sie versprechen?
Nee, die sind's wohl nicht.
Das ist wahrscheinlich nur bei ihrer Büchse mit speziellem Bios, ne?
Genau.
Also, weil schon allein das übliche, ich warte mal drauf, ob er jetzt das Bios betreten will, da dauert nicht länger als die sieben Sekunden. Aber es ist auf jeden Fall sehr schnell, dann lockt man sich da ein. Und dann hat man einen Fullscreen-Webbrowser am wesentlichen vor sich. Viel mehr kann man darüber wirklich erstmal nicht berichten, oder? Sie haben einen riesengroßen Chrome-Browser, haben dann dazu ein paar neue Features eingefügt. So eine Art Startmenü, was so ein bisschen aufgepimpte Bookmarks sind. Wie heißen diese Permataps vorne?
Permataps?
Ich weiß nicht, ich nenne die jetzt einfach. Also die haben so kleine, schmale Taps, wo man nur das Pfaffeigen sieht.
Also du musst mir jetzt echt erklären, ich hatte keine Gelegenheit, das mal live selber zu testen. Ich habe nur dieses Image irgendwie auch gehabt und dachte mal, das kopierst du jetzt mal auf dem Stick und guckst mal, was dein iMac sagt, wenn du davon bootest und dann...
Der iMac sagt da gar nichts.
Gut, er sagt eh nichts. Aus zwei Gründen. Erstens habe ich irgendwie auch das falsche Device genommen. Zweitens, ja, fiel mir dann einfach wieder die Zeit.
Ja, also das ist... Also Chrome haben wir ja mittlerweile wahrscheinlich alle mal gesehen, wie das aussieht und das ist dann halt diese Chrometaps auch oben. Dann hat man so als Bedienelemente, so was man vom Betriebssystem sieht, ist rechts oben, kann man halt die WLAN-Einstellung und die LAN-Einstellung. Mehr gibt es da im Augenblick noch nicht. Irgendwie ist da noch ein zweites Menü da, das habe ich mir aber noch nicht so genau angeguckt. Und oben links, als vorderster Tab quasi, ist ein Startmenü, was dann auch so einfach im Wesentlichen, glaube ich, eine eigene Seite ist, auf der man im Augenblick noch nicht viel sehen kann, weil dafür bräuchte man Google-Account. Das war nicht so ein Gmail-Account, sondern Google-Account im Sinne von ich bin Mitarbeiter von Google, um diese Seite zu sehen. Darüber hinaus sind da aber noch so ein paar vordefinierte Google-Kalender- und Google-Mail-Taps und da kann man sich auch mal weiter anzufügen. So weit, so total langweilig. Was sie jetzt noch gemacht haben, ist, es gibt Spezial-Webseiten, habe ich allerdings noch keine gefunden, bzw. ich habe es mir jetzt auch noch nicht so lange angeguckt, die man dann quasi unten in so einer Task-Leiste einblenden kann. Das sind dann so wie Pop-up-Fenster, die sich so oben drüber legen, über das normale Fenster, so für Chat zum Beispiel. Und die bleiben auch offen, wenn du den Tab wechselst. Und die kann man ein- und ausblenden, wie man gerade mag. Also man kann parallel eine Webseite sehen und dabei nebenbei noch chatten, zum Beispiel. Die können dann auch da noch Defikten anzeigen.
Und die gehen entweder so als Pop-ups oder als fester Sidebar, dass die sozusagen immer drinnen und drinnen von dem Spaceweg gehen.
Stimmt, als Sidebar kann man sie auch noch durchlaufen lassen. Oh, das hab ich auch gesehen. Ich finde, das macht einen sehr spannenden Eindruck. Also, klar, ich und du, wir werden jetzt sicherlich nicht übermorgen auf Chrome OS wechseln, weil wir haben fette Maschinen, mit denen wir arbeiten wollen. Aber wenn jetzt meine Oma auf mich zukommen wollte und sagen würde, sie würde gerne mal dieses Interweb ausprobieren, dann würde ich mir durchaus überlegen, sobald sowas da ist, zu sagen, hier kauft ihr auch so eine Chrome OS-Büchse, da kannst du nichts falsch machen. Und das würde es wahrscheinlich dann auch mit Mobilfunkverträgen relativ bald günstig geben. Und dann hat man da alles.
Haben sie das gesagt?
Gehe ich mal fest von aus.
Du gehst davon aus? Ich wollte nur wissen, ob du davon ausgehst oder ob das jetzt...
Sie wollen mit einigen Anbietern das zusammenbauen. Es ist ja nicht so sehr ihr Ding, das als Standalone-Distribution irgendwie rauszuschmeißen, sondern das soll ja mit ausgewählten Anbietern... Klar, man kann sich immer noch als Open Source aus dem Netz runterladen, aber du kaufst das Gerät, hast da dein Chrome OS vorinstalliert, also hast da das Internet vorinstalliert drauf. Ja, im Wesentlichen, das ist ja das. Und man lockt sich ja auch an der Kiste, also es gibt einen lokalen Username, aber mit dem muss man gar nicht unbedingt besonders viel machen, sondern man lockt sich ein mit dem Google-Account. Mit deinem Google-Account. Was sehr lustig ist... Weil alles von vornherein...
Und wenn man das nicht tut, kann man das Internet nicht benutzen?
Doch, doch, das kannst du auch benutzen. Aber wenn du dich mit deinem Google-Account einlocks, dann ist halt alles so, wie es beim letzten Mal war.
Und wenn du mit mehreren Google-Accounts arbeiten möchtest, dann stehst du erstmal da. It's not made for Leute with mehrere Google-Accounts.
It's not made for Leute with mehrere Google-Accounts. Hast du mehrere Google-Accounts, die du tatsächlich benutzen kannst?
Ja.
Ich lasse das ja tatsächlich alles auf einer Adresse laufen.
Nee, es gibt verschiedene Gründe, warum man da mehrere... Also wenn man so Google-Apps verwendet und so weiter, da willst du dann irgendwie...
Ich lasse das trotzdem immer noch alles auf einem Account laufen.
Aber... Es gab noch irgendeinen anderen Grund, warum ich mehrere Google-Accounts habe. Manche teile ich mir auch mit anderen Leuten, zum Beispiel, da will ich nicht unbedingt, dass sie auf meinem mitarbeiten. Und naja, Gott weiß ja, wie das ist. Manchmal braucht man auch einfach eine zweite Identität. Also Google-Accounts ist halt auch super, um mal einfach ein paar Sachen irgendwo zu tun, ohne jetzt gleich den eigenen... Na ja, ich benutze One Password. Das hilft. Ansonsten, wenn ich mal so kurz irgendwo rein will, ohne jetzt meine anderen Dinge, die ich unter Umständen mit einem anderen Account gerade mache, zu tun, dann nehme ich einfach ein Zweit- und Drittbrowser.
Apropos One Password, da gibt es jetzt gerade, kostenlos, kostenlos, die Pro-Version von diesem Password-App auf dem iPhone.
Ach, wirklich? Ja.
Also, musst du gucken, was haben sie jetzt für einen Black Friday oder so was gemacht, oder zum Schein.
Okay, aber lass uns mal bei Chrome ausbleiben. Wir können das irgendwie uns notieren, während ich die Applikation im Hintergrund kaufe. Also, ich meine, haben wir denn die Funktionalität jetzt schon? Hast du die jetzt schon komplett?
Eigentlich ist die gesamte Funktionalität, du hast einen Webbrowser, der aufgeht, sobald dein Rechner startet. Und dein Betriebssystem ist dein Webbrowser. Und das geht immer...
Wie ist das so mit Local Storage? Es gibt doch auch noch die Möglichkeit, USB-Sticks einzustecken und Bilder hochzuladen.
Habe ich alles noch nicht versucht. Ja, es gibt Local Storage. Ich glaube, ich weiß im Augenblick gibt es noch gar keinen File Manager in irgendeiner Form. Außer über File-Doppel-Punkt-Splash. Also wie gesagt über den Browser. Wahrscheinlich werden sie einfach auch diesen File-View ein bisschen aufbohren vom Chrome. Gehe ich mal fest von aus. Also ich glaube nicht, dass die da ernsthaft Programme darauf pappen werden, sondern da wird alles, was über diese Tab-Leiste oben hinaus ist, wird wahrscheinlich HTML sein.
Gehe ich fest von aus.
Und naja, ich meine, für viele Leute ist es, die kaufen sich einen Computer, weil sie ins Internet gehen wollen. Und warum soll da noch großartig irgendwo für die ein Äpfelchen auf der einen Seite sein oder ein Windows-Menü unten?
Du meinst, hier sind Leute, die das Netbook kaufen?
Quasi, in erster Linie, ja.
Das denke ich auch, weil ich meine, mit einem Netbook kann man wirklich nicht ernsthaft irgendetwas tun auf dem Rechner selbst, sondern eigentlich, wenn man damit was tut, tut man das.
Weil man kann schon was auf dem Gerät mitmachen.
Ja, aber ich meine, realistisch. Macht irgendjemand auf dem Netbook lokale Tätigkeiten? Selbstverständlich wird es solche Leute geben, aber jetzt so im Wesentlichen.
Dann mach ich auf meinem Macbook ernsthaft noch lokale Tätigkeiten.
Definitiv, massig.
Ich auch noch, aber...
Ich tue unglaublich viele Sachen auf meinem Mac, die ich nicht mit einem Netbook tun könnte.
Vom Reich noch nicht.
Zum Beispiel Daten nicht im Internet speichern tue ich auf jeden Fall schon mal auf meinem Macbook. Das ist schon mal ein ganz entscheidender Aspekt.
Ja, aber spätestens, wenn du dann...
Sound-Dateien bearbeiten, Videodateien bearbeiten, Umfangreiche, komplexe Dokumente mit umfangreichen und komplexen Programmen bearbeiten. Klar, gibt es für das eine oder andere irgendwie eine Lösung. Aber sowas wie Keynote kenne ich nicht im Internet. Da gibt es zwar so Präsentationsprogramme und dieses und jenes, aber... Ja, na klar, ich weiß es gibt so Ansätze. Bloß bis die wirklich mal da sind, mir denselben Komfort zu bieten. Also allein schon ein lokal vorhandenes großes Bild in einer hohen Auflösung. Da will ich ja nicht erst mal 5 Stunden warten, bis das da hochgeladen ist. Und ich kann auch nicht den kompletten Datenvorrat meiner 300 Gigabyte Festplatte, die total gefüllt ist, die ich jetzt auf 500 habe, upgraden müssen und so weiter.
Ja, natürlich, also es ist natürlich auch eine Wette auf die Zukunft von Seiten Google. Also im Augenblick kann man darüber ein bisschen Mail machen und ein bisschen YouTube-Videos gucken und wahrscheinlich auch ein bisschen schneiden und so was, aber das werden sie auch garantiert hinzufügen. Aber es ist natürlich irgendwie auch, ich weiß gar nicht, ob es so ein extremer Schuss gegen Microsoft ist, es ist wahrscheinlich dann eher so ein Kollateralschaden, dass plötzlich Netbooks verkauft werden, an denen Microsoft keinen Cent mehr verdient. Und wo die Firmenmitarbeiter wahrscheinlich, oder wo die Firmen dann noch einen deutlich geringeren Supportaufwand haben, weil so ein Betriebssystem, was so aus der Cloud kommt, das ist natürlich auch eine geile Sache, was so Updates angeht.
Also ich sehe auch durchaus da eine Möglichkeit, für Google zu punkten. Aber jetzt habe ich noch nicht damit gearbeitet, deswegen ist es gerade etwas schwer, das zu beurteilen.
Was ich mich ein bisschen frage, warum sie das nicht von vornherein für Android so gemacht haben.
Was?
Na, dieser Alles-Web-Apps-Ansatz. Palm hat das gemacht. Und Google, warum bringen die jetzt noch ein zweites Betriebssystem nur dafür raus? Warum machen die nicht hier auf dieses Telefon eine schnelle HTML-Engine, genauso wie es Apple getan hat?
Na ja, weil sie wahrscheinlich auch sehen, also ganz klar, weil Performance ist ein wichtiger Punkt. Guck dir an, wie toll ein 3GS ist im Vergleich zum 3G. Warum? Weil es auf einmal alles mega snappy läuft. Und das ist genau das, was du von so einem Handset erwartest. Und auf so einem ARM-Prozessor, einem mobilen ARM-Prozessor mit JavaScript-Anwendung, wo das irgendwie auf unseren Rechnern teilweise noch nicht snappy läuft. Ich meine, Google Wave irgendwie, ja, da kannst du irgendwie in 8-Core...
Das möchte ich schon am Augenblick auch nicht.
Ja gut, aber du weißt, was ich meine. Das ist einfach, Performance kriegst du am Ende dann, wenn du wirklich hochgradig auf deine Architektur optimierst. Das ist durchaus vorstellbar, dass dieses V8 und auch die JavaScript-Engine von WebKit und alle anderen natürlich auch, sich jetzt im Zuge dieser aktuellen Compiler-Revolution, die wir ja auch schon ein paar Mal besprochen haben, dass die wirklich so gute Compilation-Times, also auch Runtime-Compilation, also Übersetzungen zur Laufzeit, erreichen werden, dass das irgendwann nicht mehr so ein wahrzunehmender Performance-Vorsprung ist, den eine Native-App, die einmal vorkompiliert wurde, erreichen kann. Bloß da sind wir noch nicht.
Na ja, aber ich meine so, das ist ja...
Pri ist ja auch nicht gerade, jetzt wird ja auch nicht gerade dafür gelobt, wie schnell er ist.
Pri geht es übrigens wahrscheinlich die Tage mal einzutesten, dann kann ich selber flochen über die Langsamkeit. Nee, aber warum Google das Web... Also ich meine, dass man so für einige Spezialfälle meinetwegen dann auch eine tiefe Applikation hat, okay, als Kompromiss. Aber man muss sagen, dass der Web-Browser bei Google Android wirklich stiefmütterlich behandelt wird eigentlich. Also das ist der... Safari auf dem iPhone ist wesentlich weiter als der Browser auf dem Android.
Ja gut, am Ende des Tages muss es halt einfach auch hinkriegen. Ich meine, alles wollen und wünschen und möchten ist das eine. Und es dann auch wirklich gehackt zu bekommen ist das andere. Ich sehe da durchaus Potenzial. Ich meine, jetzt ihre Vision für Android ist ja nun so schlecht nicht. Auch ihre neue Maps-Geschichte und keine Ahnung. Ich wollte jetzt aber doch noch mal so ein bisschen bei dem Chromo erst bleiben. Es ist ja nun jetzt wirklich die Frage, was das jetzt erstmal bedeutet. Ich meine, erstmal bedeutet das sowieso überhaupt nichts, weil so richtig da ist das ohnehin erst in einem Jahr. Sie setzen jetzt von vornherein schon mal frühzeitig auf eine Open-Source-Adoption, was ganz interessant ist, dass sie jetzt schon halt damit rausgehen.
Ja, es haben ja mittlerweile auch die Spatzen von den Dächern gebrüllt, dass das kommen wird.
Ja gut, aber deswegen müssen sie es ja noch nicht releasen.
Sie hatten es ja versehentlich sogar schon mal released. Ich weiß nicht, ob du das mitbekommen hattest. Das ist, dass plötzlich auf dem Server, auf dem so die Chromium Knightlies auftauchen, die Builds, da gibt es ja eine Webseite, wo man sich immer so für Linux und für Mac und Windows die Knightly Builds runterladen kann. Und da gab es plötzlich einen Chromium OS Ordner. Und das hat sich dann mal jemand runtergeladen und hat dann plötzlich sein Ubuntu mal, hatte dann plötzlich Chrome OS.
Okay, den habe ich nicht mitbekommen, aber das war sicherlich ein Unfall. Trotz alledem müssen sie ja nicht da gleich drauf reagieren. Also es zwingt sie ja keiner, es trotzdem zu releasen. Wie auch immer, sie haben sich jetzt dazu entschlossen, das zu tun, aus welchen Beweggründen auch immer. Ich denke, dass sie einfach grundsätzlich natürlich ein Interesse daran haben, wenn das Netz mitzieht. So, und das ist bei Valve so. Und das ist bei Chromium OS so, das ist bei Chrome so. Sie haben sich einfach für den Weg entschlossen, dass sie ihre Kernsoftware-Sachen, die jetzt OS-Style haben, Plattformen sind, dass sie die halt open sourcen. Weil ich denke, da glauben sie auch da dran oder da meinen sie zu wissen, dass es einfach keine andere Möglichkeit gibt, den Markt von unten aufzurollen. Weil sie sind ja im Prinzip noch Anfänger, was Software betrifft, zumindest was Endkunden-Software betrifft. Gut, so, das machen sie so. Aber wenn sie Chromium OS erst in einem Jahr fertigstellen, hätten sie ja auch noch warten können. Sie versprechen sich also offensichtlich auch was davon, das so früh zu releasen.
Naja, ist das natürlich immer für... Das ist ja auch, wenn du in einem Marktsegment aktiv bist schon, dann kündigst du neue Produkte so spät wie möglich an, weil du möchtest verhindern, dass die Leute, die alten nicht mehr kaufen, weil sie aufs Neue warten. Wenn du Autohersteller bist, wenn du aber in ein neues Marktsegment gehst, dann probierst du dich möglichst früh zu positionieren und darauf hinzuweisen, dass du da jetzt auch... Also, sie sind ja nicht Apple.
Ja, eben. Apple, was ist man? Microsoft, Vaporware, davon reden wir, oder was?
Nee, auch Autohersteller, wenn die ein neues Auto vorstellen. Wenn das im alten Marktsegment ist, dann kommt das immer relativ spät erst. Aber wenn das, was ich als Mercedes die A-Klasse vorgestellt hatte, irgendwann mal vor 100 Jahren, da haben die das schon jahrelang vorher angekündigt, damit die stramme Mercedes-Kundschaft sich nicht trotzdem noch einen Golf in der Zeit kauft oder. Ein Polo.
Ja, gut, ich meine, das ist dann auch die Frage, inwieweit man sowas wirklich geheim halten kann. Ich meine, bei so viel dieser Zulieferbranche, also Automarkt und Computermarktvermarkten, möchte ich jetzt wirklich nicht miteinander vergleichen. Das ist schon auch ein bisschen was anderes. Aber ich frage mich halt, was sozusagen der Impact tatsächlich sein kann. Und Google Stoßrichtung generell ist ja die, sie wollen eine Alternative sein, bieten zu Microsoft. Android bekämpft nicht das iPhone, Android bekämpft Windows Mobile und ist da auch offensichtlich sehr erfolgreich mit. Chrome OS bekämpft Windows XP auf Netbox. Das ist das, worum es geht. Und es bietet sozusagen die Möglichkeit, einen billigen Einstieg in die Nutzung des Internets.
Das sehe ich tatsächlich ein bisschen anders. Ich glaube nicht, dass es Google wirklich, ich weiß nicht, ob es denen wirklich darum geht, jetzt Microsoft unbedingt...
Es geht ihnen nicht nur im wesentlichen wegen Microsoft um Microsoft, sondern es ist so, dass Microsoft natürlich für sie das größte Hindernis ist, das zu erreichen, worauf sie eigentlich hinauswollen, nämlich eine internetbasierte Computing-Infrastruktur zu etablieren auf diesem Planeten.
Wie von ihnen dominiert wird.
Genau. Wo sie zumindest überhaupt erst mal mitspielen können. Dass sie dann auch noch in der Lage sind, einzelne Märkte davon zu dominieren. Sie dominieren ja nicht alle Märkte, auf denen sie sind. So wie Apple das nicht tut, wie auch Microsoft das nicht tut. Aber es gibt halt definitiv diesen OS-Markt, und der ist eben nicht unerheblich. Wir wissen alle, was Windows für eine Blockadepolitik ist im Vergleich zu allen anderen internetbasierten Anwendungen. Microsoft steht im zunehmenden Maße schlechter da. Sie sind natürlich noch da. Sie sind auch in diesem Netbook-Markt. Das, was bisher an Linux-Lösungen für Netbooks rauskam, das war so attraktiv nicht.
Sie haben diesen Netbook-Markt schön von hinten aufgerollt.
Wer?
Microsoft. Am Anfang war das alles Linux, weil Windows viel zu teuer war für diese kleinen Plätze. Und Windows XP lief schon immer theoretisch auf den Dingern. Das war in erster Linie die Lizenzpolitik. Und dann haben sie dieses Windows XP, weil sie das mitbekommen haben, für Netbooks rausgebracht. Mit einfach nur, es ist billiger, wenn der Rechner nicht die technischen Daten überschreitet. Und schon lohnt sich das nicht mehr für die Hersteller, da ein Linux draufzupappen. Und damit haben sie den Markt wieder zurückgeholt. Mittlerweile ist es ja echt ein Problem, Netbooks ohne Windows zu kriegen.
Ja, ist das so?
Ja, die haben alle Windows vorinstalliert. Windows XP meistens.
Weil die Netbooks mittlerweile auch die Performance-Kriterien erfüllen, die XP beim Release an Computer mal gestellt haben.
Darüber sind die schon deutlich drüber.
Das ist schon ganz schön lange her mit dem XP.
Das ist ewig her. Ich hab neulich mal wieder geguckt, was es da so gibt. Von Dell gibt es auch einen mit Windows 7 drauf. Kostet ein Zehner mehr als die Version mit Windows XP. Bei Dell haben noch eine Ubuntu-Variante drinne, die soll offiziell supporten. Ja, aber wirklich nur eine ganz kleine, abgespeckte Variante.
Gut, wie auch immer. Chromo S positioniert sich an der Stelle. Ich denke aber nicht, dass sie jetzt der große Windows-Killer sind. Sie können aber durchaus der Windows-Killer im Netbook-Markt sein. Also Killer ist immer so ein überzogenes Wort, aber ich denke, dass sie da eine Chance haben, einen ähnlichen Erfolg zu landen, wie mit Android auf den Handsets. So, weil das hat definitiv Windows ein Problem bereitet. Das ist nicht das Einzige, was Windows ein Problem, also Windows Mobile ein Problem bereitet hat, aber das ist definitiv Teil der Geschichte. Und genauso kann ich mir vorstellen, dass Chromo an der Stelle eben auch Teil der Geschichte Einfluss von Windows auf Netbooks sinkt. Einfach aus dem, was du nämlich am Anfang gesagt hast, dass das eben für viele Leute ausreicht, nur quasi eine Basis für den Internetzugang zu haben, weil du mit Applikationen so groß jetzt gar nicht arbeiten willst, vor allem weil es auch sozusagen der Zweitrechner ist.
Es gibt immer mehr Applikationen im Netz, auch einfach. Also ich meine, das ist so, wenn ich jetzt meinen Rechner gerade angucke, dann habe ich da Google Wave offen, was nur ein Fenster ist, in dem eine Webseite läuft. Ich habe Google Mail offen, ich nutze den ganzen Tag über Twitter, ich nutze eigentlich den ganzen Tag über sehr, sehr viele Web-Anwendungen. Und dass davon ein Teil über APIs auch noch nativ auf meinen Rechner kommen, gut und schön. Aber wenn die APIs entsprechend gut sind, dass das auch direkt in der Webseite ablaufen kann, umso besser. Und das ist schon, und wenn ich mich nicht mehr um Updates kümmern brauche, um Viren, um so einen Scheiß, dann verzichte ich auch mal, also dann gehe ich auch das Risiko vielleicht ein, dass da mal einer der Server down ist oder ich mal ein Update bekomme, weil es nicht so ganz so 100%ig läuft, was ja auch die Nachteile wären.
Okay, ich denke, mehr müssen wir jetzt zu Chrome OS nicht verlieren. Aber bleiben wir nochmal bei Google. Es gibt da noch ein paar andere interessante Vorstellungen. Ich weiß jetzt gar nicht von wann das ist, aber das hat auch ein bisschen mit Chrome zu tun. Hast du schon mal von SPDY gehört?
Ich würde sagen, das wird Speedy ausgesprochen, oder?
Ja, aber geschrieben wird es SPDY.
Ist das dieses Http-Dingsbums-Erweiterung, die Sie jetzt vorgeplant haben?
Genau. Ich bewundere Ihren Ansatz, Sachen, die einfach nicht wirklich gut funktionieren und die schon immer so waren, einfach mal in Frage zu stellen und neu zu machen. Das ist jetzt hier quasi Teil 2, wenn man jetzt mal Chrome OS als Teil 1 sieht. Aber bei SPDY ist es halt einfach, okay, sagen wir SPDY, geht es halt einfach darum, das Hauptproblem von HTTP zu bekämpfen, was sie natürlich erheblich haben, was nicht nur der User hat, sondern was natürlich auch Google hat beim Crawlen des Web, das Latenz. Genauso wie bei Audio ist auch bei HTTP die Latenz, sprich die Antwortzeiten, bis du mal irgendwie eine Antwort auf ein Request kriegst und bis du dann auch den nächsten wieder schicken kannst. Alles irgendwie asynchron zu machen, das ist irgendwie total knifflig.
Und bei HTTP werden ja extrem viele Anfragen geschickt.
Es werden extrem viele Anfragen geschickt. Im Prinzip gibt es auch einen hohen Bedarf für Parallelität, der dann aber effektiv bedeutet, dass du halt auch immer wieder eine neue TCP-Verbindung aufbauen musst. Und dafür gehen dann auch mal mehrere Pakete hin und her, bis diese Verbindung erstmal aufgebaut ist. Also bis du überhaupt erstmal deine HTTP-Daten in einem Paket schicken kannst, musst du halt erstmal einen Hallo, ich will eine TCP-Verbindung aufbauen. Dann sagt der so, ja, ich habe zur Kenntnis genommen, dass du eine aufbauen willst, kannst du machen. Und dann musst du nochmal einen, ja, jetzt habe ich das auch zur Kenntnis genommen, dass du das zur Kenntnis genommen hast und ich will jetzt hier auch den Vollzug durchführen. Und dann geht es ja erst los, dass da Datenpakete kommen und mit Sliding Windows und Pipa Pro. Ist alles ein relativ hoher Aufwand, will man nicht immer wieder machen. Und deswegen haben sie jetzt diese Speedy da vorgeschlagen, und übrigens auch in Chrome eingebaut. Ja, schrieben sie. Ich weiß nicht, benutzt habe ich es jetzt nicht. Und dann wollen sie sozusagen über diese Verbindung asynchron HTTP-Requests machen.
Nein, nicht nur das, sondern wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, heißt es ja in erster Linie, dass quasi in der Seite oben drin steht, übrigens ich brauche zum Aufbau dieser Seite folgende Dateien. Und die kriegst du hier in einem Request. Hab ich das richtig verstanden?
Ich weiß noch nicht mal, ob ich das richtig verstanden habe. Ich hab mir halt so ein bisschen die Beschreibung durchgelesen und sie haben halt auch verschiedene Prior Art verwiesen, wie diese und andere Probleme da auch schon mal angegangen werden sollen, teilweise auch mit einem Ersetzen durch TCP. Aber sie wollen halt den Aufwand relativ gering halten und nur Änderungen im Client und Server durchführen.
Also das große Problem ist ja, wenn man so eine HTML-Seite lädt, dann wird zuerst die HTML-Seite geladen, dann wird...
CSS, JavaScript-Dateien.
CSS, JavaScript-Dateien. Teilweise läuft die Scheiße asynchron, zum Beispiel bei Bildern oder CSS-Dateien. Also das heißt, dass die Seite sich durchaus weiter aufbaut, während man sie schon sieht. Teilweise aber auch bei JavaScript ist das ganz, ganz böse. Wenn jetzt irgendwo in der Seite JavaScript auftaucht, dann bleibt der Webbrowser stehen und sagt, ok, ich brauch jetzt erstmal die JavaScript-Datei. Und dann wird die erstmal geladen. Und solange der Server nicht geantwortet hat und nicht die JavaScript-Seite geladen hat, passiert erstmal gar nichts. Und ganz besonders dramatisch ist das, wenn du irgendeinen Werbebanner drinne hast, weil da steht es nämlich bei den meisten Werbebanner drin. Du, lad mal die JavaScript-Datei! Und dann hast du eine ganze Kaskade von JavaScript-Dateien. Wer sich das schon mal ein bisschen genauer angetan hat, wundert sich, dass so werbebetriebene Seiten überhaupt laufen. Weil das ist echt krass, was da auch langsam Server-Kaskaden dahinter hängt. Und wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, wollen sie jetzt quasi oben in das HTML ein Header mit reinpacken. Oder auf jeden Fall irgendwo eine Information hinterlegen. Du, für die Seite brauche ich folgende Dateien. Und hier kriegst du sie. Ohne, dass du es explizit nachgefragt hast.
In das HTML?
Ich weiß nicht, ob das... Nee, in das HTML bin ich jetzt nicht sicher.
Das BDS ist jetzt sozusagen nichts anderes als ein Session-Layer für HTTP.
Ach so, okay.
Das heißt, du packst das sozusagen da drunter und machst darüber alles das, was du auch vorher gemacht hast, nur dass eben das alles über eine einzige Verbindung gemultiplext wird. Du hast dann sozusagen nicht mehrere TCP-Verbindungen, die dann immer wieder für jeden Request aufgebaut werden, sondern du hast so ein Session-Layer, der das alles über eine einzige Verbindung macht. Und das dann auch über SSL. Das heißt, sie wollen damit sozusagen auch gleichzeitig SSL pushen, weil sie der Meinung sind, dass es sowieso mal ganz sinnvoll ist. Und da liegen sie ja auch nicht falsch.
Dann gibt es keine nicht verschlüsselte mehr, oder wie über Speedy? Geht das nur über SSL oder auch über SSL?
Es ist, ähm, sie sagen, es sei die Underlying Transport Protocol.
Jetzt ist Session-Layer top auf SSL?
Also genau genommen ist es irgendwie der Presentation-Layer, weil darunter ist ja noch TCP, aber das ist schon Teil der Geschichte. Ich bin mir jetzt nicht so sicher, welche Auswirkungen das so hat. Ich meine, man hat ja dann gleich wieder das IP-Adressen und Zertifikate-Problem. Aber das ist das, was sie sagen. Ihnen geht es halt einfach um nicht so viel Overhead mit neuen Verbindungen. Alle HTTP-Informationen sollen komprimiert werden und unter Umständen auch nicht unbedingt doppelt und dreifach gesendet werden, weil irgendwie dein User-Agent musst du nicht jedes Mal mitschicken, der bleibt dann irgendwie gleich. Und eben SSL, damit es einfach sicher ist. Das ist nämlich ganz interessant, dass auch der Server eine Verbindung zum Client aufbauen kann.
Damit man endlich mal vernünftiges Push implementieren kann.
So, das ist sozusagen alles mit drin. Ich denke, das ist alles noch so ein bisschen im...
Okay, dann hab ich es schlicht und ergreifend komplett falsch verstanden....
im offenen Feld. Sie bezeichnen das ja auch selber als experimentelles Protokoll. Den Bereich des Webs aufzurollen, das kann selbst Google nicht immer so eben machen. Aber es ist natürlich immer interessant zu sehen, was sie so als Lösungsvorschläge im Sack haben. Und das fand ich jetzt auch ganz interessant. Ja heißt, wir schreiten zum nächsten Thema. Und das ist der dritte Google.
Ich nehme Google für 1.000.
Genau, Google 100, Google 200, Google 300.
So, das ist?
Da haben wir letztes Mal noch nicht drüber geredet.
Glaubst du das letztes Mal schon?
Ich hab mit so vielen Leuten drüber geredet, aber ich hatte es zumindest nicht in unseren...
Ich fand es jetzt nicht so spektakulär, ehrlich gesagt.
Da hab ich auch ganz viele Leute getroffen, die das nicht spektakulär fanden.
Das ist eine neue Programmiersprache?
Es ist eine neue Programmiersprache. Und sie heißt Go oder Go.
Und ist so ein bisschen C-artig, wenn ich das richtig...
Und ist ein bisschen C-artig. Was auch nicht verwundert, weil das ist irgendwie von unseren Unix-Gos Rob Pike und Richie entwickelt worden, die auch mal so C verbrochen haben und Unix und all das. Und es ist sehr C-artig, aber ich meine, das ist insofern keine Überraschung, als dass fast alle Poemiersprachen heutzutage C-artig sind. Also, ich meine, es gibt nicht wirklich viele Sprachen, die nicht C-artig sind. Aber auch da, also bestimmte Dinge sind dann halt einfach ähnlich. Aber das ist halt einfach nochmal, die Heritage ist definitiv C. Allerdings haben sie sich schon bemüht, da jetzt mehr zu machen als nur C+. Genau, sie haben sich auch bemüht, keinen C++ zu machen. Sondern sie reden ja von einer Systems-Level-Sprache.
Also es geht schon relativ weit unten. Es ist schon wirklich nicht so eine dieser hippenneuen Skriptsprachen, sondern es ist wirklich schon noch nah am Blech dran.
Ja, es ist nah am Blech und auch nicht. Also findet ihr, dass sie da einen ganz interessanten Weg gehen. Wie fangen wir denn damit an? Also erstens, es handelt sich dabei um eine kompilierte Programmiersprache. Sie ist in ihrer ganzen Sündagserscheinung her C-ähnlich, sehr ähnlich und hat allerdings an einigen Stellen, ich weiß nicht, ob ich jetzt alle gesehen habe, es gab ja da dieses einstündige Präsentationsvideo von dem Pike, wo er das halt so ein bisschen erklärt hat und er hatte da nicht viel Zeit, also eine Stunde für eine neue Purimiersprache ist ja jetzt nicht so üppig. Aber zum Beispiel die Deklaration von Variablen, wenn du mehrere in einer Zeile schreibst, dann schreibst du den Typ als Ende, wo du ihn vorher an Anfang geschrieben hast und so. Das sind so Kleinigkeiten oder beim If hast du keine Klammern mehr. Im Wesentlichen haben sie ausgemistet, um einfach weniger schreiben zu müssen. Was sie aber Gott sei Dank nicht gemacht haben, ist diesen Unsinn von Pilsen zu wiederholen, mit diesem, meine Texteditoreinrückung gibt die Struktur des Programms vor. Ich weiß, dass es da glühende Verfechter davon gibt. Ich weiß aber auch mittlerweile, warum ich da definitiv keinen glühenden Verfechter jemals von werden kann, weil das eben der Sprache signifikante Nachteile gebracht hat bei Pilsen, die, glaube ich, nicht so allgemein anerkannt werden, aber wo jeder dann, wenn man das mal erklärt, dann auch im Kopf schütteln muss. Also, vertikal.
Ich habe ein bisschen neulich mal ganz furchtbar einfach über die Tab aus, also diese Tab versus Spaces-Diskussion oder, was heißt Diskussion? Es gibt ja keine Diskussion. Ich stelle einfach fest, dass immer mehr Leute Spaces vorne anquellen. Ich bin für Tabs.
Und siehst du mal, da wird es nämlich auch interessant. Der Style-Guide, sie haben nämlich so Pretty Printing quasi auch mitdefiniert. Und es gibt quasi bei Go, es gibt so eine Funktion, die das sozusagen dann auch automatisch herstellt, weil sie eben das parsen und wissen, wie die Eindrückung zu sein hat. Und sie nehmen Tabs.
Sehr gut.
Da kann man jetzt sagen, das ist natürlich die alte Oldschool-Fraktion.
Was heißt alte Oldschool-Fraktion?
Tab ist einfach Oldschool. Ich meine, angenommen, du hättest dir in den 80er Jahren sowas vorgeschlagen, wie vier Spaces statt eines Tabs zu nehmen, denn man hätte dich einfach wegen Bandbreitenvergeudung verbrannt.
Ja, zurecht.
Ja, zurecht. Ich meine, heute ist das mit irgendwie Kompression im Fallsystem und so weiter.
Das sind wertvolle vier Bytes auf meiner Seite.
Ja, das sind vor allem wertvolle vier Bytes, wenn sie irgendwie übertragen werden. Ich meine, damals wurde es ja schon gehängt, wenn du irgendwie eine dreizeitige Signature hast und keine zweizeitige. Oder irgendwie gewagt hast, mehr als diese vorgeschriebenen zwei Minus Minus davor zu machen in deiner E-Mail.
Aber der Grund, warum ich für Taps bin, ist eher, weil die Leute gerne dazu neigen, irgendwie zwei Leerzeichen vorzupacken. Und ich hab gerne vier.
Ja, dann kann man das einfach in seinem Minitur einstellen. Ja, Taps haben einfach drei Taps drin. Also Taps sind einfach super. Der Chat fragt natürlich jetzt, was an der Python-Eindrückung schlecht ist, kann ich schnell mal ein Beispiel nennen. Ich nenne auch genau nur dieses eine Beispiel, weil erstens fallen mir jetzt nicht mehr ein und das reicht mir auch schon. Es gibt halt da unter anderem solche Konstrukte wie Closures. Und dann so Kurzschreibweisen, wie du mal eben so etwas Code in einer Zeile schreibst und so eine anonyme Funktion reintust. Das ist ja eine tolle Sache. So was braucht eine Programmiersprache auch. So, dadurch, dass du es aber in einer Zeile schreibst, kannst du natürlich in dieser einen Zeile keinen IF unterbringen, wie du das sonst schreibst, weil es geht ja zwangsläufig über mehrere Zeilen, weil ja der Zeilenreturn ja sagt, wo es anfängt und aufhört. Also hast du dafür eine andere Syntax für IF. Das heißt, du hast für sowas wie IF, schreibst es halt anders, wenn du es über mehrere Zeilen normal in deinem Code hast oder in so einer Clojure drin hast. Das bricht einfach komplett mit dem Ansatz, dass man eben Sachen nur einmal definiert. Und wenn es sich um dasselbe handelt, dass du das dann auch auf dieselbe Art und Weise machst. Und das geht einfach bei Paisen katastrophal verloren. Und da gibt es, glaube ich, ausreichend Verblendung, das nicht zu sehen. Und man kann da jetzt auch andere Meinungen drüber sein. Aber das ist jetzt das, was ich... Ja, so. Und Go nimmt halt geschweifte Klammern für einen Blog und fertig. Finde ich vollkommen okay. Geschweifte Klammern haben sich einfach etabliert. Außer bei Ruby? Wer in der Lage ist... Ja, bei Dillon ist es auch nicht drin. Da hast du halt irgendwie Beginn und End. Aber die kannst du halt auch in einer Zeile schreiben. Das ist nochmal eine andere Geschichte, ob man da jetzt eher verbose sein möchte oder nicht. Insofern sind Geschweifte Klammern eigentlich ein wunderbarer Mittelweg zwischen Ters sein, also wenig schreiben müssen, aber trotzdem nicht in irgendeinen Formatierungskonstrukt gefangen zu werden. Und auch Reformatierungen machen zu können.
Wide Space & Code sind ein schönes Ausdrucksmittel im Sinne von ich kann auch mal, also ich probiere den immer so zu verteilen, dass ich das nach Wichtigkeit, also wenn irgendwie was, auch relativ komplexer Code, wenn er aber nur jetzt dafür ist, um eine Ausgabe zu machen, die eigentlich relativ unwichtig ist und die man vielleicht sogar schon in eine eigene Methode reinpacken sollte, dann packe ich das gerne mal in eine Zeile. Und ansonsten, aber wenn es wichtig ist für den Code, dann mache ich es ausführlicher. Und das ist eine Ausdrucksmöglichkeit, die mir glaube ich sehr fehlen würde. So bei Sprachen, die auf Wide Space & Code gehen.
Na gut, das ist ja auch nur ein Detail, aber das fand ich schon mal an sich ganz elegant gelöst. Und das zeigt aber auch, dass sie einerseits ganz gut in der Tradition hängen. Andererseits haben sie auch diverse Elemente drin, die jetzt sehr wohl auch in die Zukunft weisen. Weil jetzt nur, um das mit dem Wide Space anders zu machen und runde Klammern beim Effect zu lassen, hätte man jetzt keine neue Programmiersprache erfinden müssen. Ja, warum dann eigentlich Go? Es gibt ein ganz großes Ding bei Go, und das sind die sogenannten Go-Routines. Go ist dafür gemacht, Parallelisierung ausdrücken zu können. Und damit ist es eigentlich in der selben Abteilung wie Erlang. Erlang erfreut sich ja in manchen Nischen der Web-Entwicklung und der Hauptsoftware-Entwicklung derzeit großer Bediebtheit, insbesondere, es gibt da diesen Java-Server, der in Erlang geschrieben ist, der Facebook-Chat ist in Erlang geschrieben und CouchDB ist in Erlang geschrieben. Also all diese Dinge mit Verteilung von Prozessen, mit Asynchronizität und sowas.
Ich hab immer mit einem Erlang-Entwickler gesprochen, er meinte, sie machen es nicht, aber es ist möglich, innenlaufenden Code neuen Code zu injecten.
Das gehört sich auch so. Das konnte schon Smalltalk und Lisp. Ja, das ist Dynamik, aber das ist nicht, worum es mir jetzt geht. Es geht um diese Parallelisierungsmöglichkeit. Google hat gesagt, Performance erreicht man heute bei Rechnersystemen dadurch, dass man mehr hat. Du hast nicht eine CPU, sondern du hast 1632 oder ein Googles-File, wenn die ein komplettes Dataway-Haus nehmen und da mal in Clustern denken.
Die haben dann wahrscheinlich mehrere 10.000.
Und wenn sie eine Programmiersprache benutzen, die dich auf einen einzigen Core festhält, um irgendwas zu machen, was man aber eigentlich wunderbar parallelisieren könnte, wo es einem nur sehr schwer gemacht wird. Das Thema hatten wir schon mal, als wir hier Lipdispatch durchgesprochen haben. Go ist sozusagen eine Programmiersprache mit so etwas wie Lipdispatch eingebaut. Das heißt, das Formulieren einer Routine und das asynchrone Abwerfen. Und dann wird das irgendwie ausgeführt, wenn dafür Zeit ist. Und asynchron kannst du die Ergebnisse davon einsammeln. Das ist etwas, was sie in die Programmiersprache mit reingemacht haben. Eben auch, also nicht so wie er, also ich kenne das erlang nicht genug, um zu sagen, ob es da noch syntaktisch oder semantisch Ähnlichkeiten gibt, aber auf jeden Fall ist da ein vergleichbares Element mit drin. Dazu kommt, dass sie auch noch einen internen Datentyp haben, einen sogenannten Communication Channel, der von Standard IO bis hin zur Interprozesskommunikation alles abdeckt. Das heißt auch die Go-Routinen können untereinander über diese Kanäle kommunizieren und du musst dir keinerlei Gedanken darüber machen, auf was für ein Betriebssystem du bist, was für eine SRED-Architektur du hast, ob du da POSIX-SREDs hast oder so. Deswegen sagen sie auch, sie nennen es jetzt explizit nicht SREDs, weil der Begriff SRED sehr vorbelastet ist. Ja, das ist sehr vorbelastet in Bezug auf, wie das eben in Betriebssystemen so ist. Sie sagen halt Go-Routinen, zumal sie ja auch mehr Abstraktion drin haben. Sie haben dieses ganze Creation und so weiter ist ja alles mit drin, da musst du dich nicht drum kümmern, sondern du setzt das halt einfach nur irgendwie in die Welt und dann gibt's das. Und sie sind extrem schnell. Sie haben sehr viel Zeit darauf verwendet zu demonstrieren, wie schnell Go ist. Und zwar jetzt weniger so im Sinne, wie schnell sie bestimmte Benchmarks machen können. Da sind sie eigentlich gar nicht weiter drauf eingegangen. Das bleibt auch nochmal abzusehen, wie schnell man jetzt da mit Algorithmen implementieren kann. Meine Vermutung ist recht fix. Aber sie sind sehr schnell im Erzeugen dieser Go-Routinen. Also der hat da ein Programm gemacht, was irgendwie 100.000 Go-Routinen aufmacht und das war halt ein paar Sekunden auch beendet auf dem MacBook. Und das Kompilieren des vollständigen Source Codes, also schnell im Sinne von schnelles Rätsel erzeugen, aber dann auch was die Compile-Time betrifft. Also manchen sind auch das wäre für sie wichtig. Also es wäre nicht nur wichtig, wie schnell das Programm läuft und dass es sich gut parallelisieren lässt, damit es schnell läuft, sondern sie wollen auch, dass der Compiler schnell ist, damit die Turnaround-Zeit beim Entwickeln nie weg ist.
Kurze Entwicklungzeit, das geht es nicht.
Aber klar, ich meine, du kannst die tollste Programmiersprache haben, wenn es irgendwie jedes Mal acht Stunden dauert, dass du irgendwie zwei Zeilen Code da neu in dein Projekt mit rein nimmst, dann bremst dich das einfach maßlos aus und dann hilft es irgendwie auch nicht. Code, der schnell fertig ist, hilft manchmal auch noch mehr als Code, der zehn Prozent schneller läuft. Aber das wollen sie irgendwie beides haben und sie haben dann auf MacBook Pro, das war glaube ich so eine 15 Zoll Büchse, eine aktuelle, haben sie einfach den Compiler gestartet, um den kompletten Source Code des Compilers selbst zu kompilieren. Ich weiß jetzt nicht genau, wieviel das war, aber wir wissen alles, gehört ein bisschen Code ist schon dabei und es hat irgendwie acht Sekunden gedauert. Und du meinst so acht Sekunden, das wäre für sie jetzt mittlerweile schon die Definition einer Ewigkeit. Und normalerweise wollen sie Return, wie nannte er das?
In Return-Time.
Also sie streben eigentlich Return-Time ab.
Ich drücke Return, ich sehe wie mein...
Du drückst Return und du hast einfach prompt. Also im Sinne von sofort. Also das, was man so als sofort wahrnimmt. Man hätte Real-Time irgendwie nennen können.
Ja, also wenn man... Bibliotheken nachladen und so weiter, das wird natürlich auch in der Go ein bisschen länger dauern, als ein Compiler wahrscheinlich auch relativ dankbare Sachen, weil er nicht auf Systembibliotheken zugreift.
Entschuldigung, was wird länger dauern?
Wenn die Systembibliotheken nachladen müssen oder ähnliches, dann wird auch bei Go das Kompilieren ein bisschen länger dauern.
Nee, gerade das ist nämlich auch ein Punkt, das haben sie angesprochen. Und zwar haben sie insbesondere eben dieses Einbinden von anderen Bibliotheken beschleunigt, durch Optimierung, damit Dinge nicht zweimal geladen werden müssen. Was einmal geladen ist, wird nie wieder geladen. Da erinnere ich mich jetzt gerade nicht mehr so ganz genau an die Ausführungen, aber das war definitiv Teil der Geschichte und das ist auch ein Grund, warum das Compilen des gesamten Source-Codes so schnell ging. Okay.
Bei der X-Code schonmal, wenn man in X-Code, egal welches Projekt man kompiliert, nach 8 Sekunden sieht man vielleicht das erste Mal den Progress-Balcon sich bewegen, egal wie klein das Projekt ist.
Siehst du mal, und sie machen sozusagen ihren kompletten Compiler in 8 Sekunden vollständig durch auf dem MacBook. Und das ist schon ein Statement. Also, keine Ahnung, welche Zukunft das hat, aber ich meine, wir wissen auch, Google würde sich jetzt nicht so weit aus dem Fenster lehnen und solche Präsentationen machen, wenn sie nicht da zumindest irgendeine interne Verwendung schnuppern. So, und ich meine, man weiß, dass sie extrem viel Python einsetzen, um ihre Systeme zu skippen. Also, der ganze Google-Bereich wird extrem von Python zusammengehalten. Sicherlich nicht ausschließlich, aber zu einem Gutteil. Auch so in administrativen Bereichen. Und wenn ich mir halt anschaue, was so die Parameter von diesem Go sind und das eben so vergleiche, dann sehe ich halt, ah, ok, alles klar, damit können sie diese Dinge auch tun. Aber unter Umständen halt raten schnell.
Naja, es ist ja auch, wenn man in die berühmte Wolke rein will und ich nehme an, dass Google, die App Engine, die sie nach außen hin verkaufen, intern genauso stark einsetzen, dann geht es ja auch um massive Parallelisierbarkeit. Dann weißt du ja nicht so genau, wie viele Prozessoren habe ich jetzt wirklich zur Verfügung, aber ich will halt, dass es trotzdem immer schnell ausgeführt wird und dass es möglichst gut parallelisiert auch über die ganze Welt hinweg.
Und wenn du deine Go-Rant haben, halt irgendwie noch so eine Cluster-Verteilung darunter baust, dann geht das irgendwie ab wie Schmitzkatze, wenn du da irgendwie in so ein Google-Data-Ware-Haus dran passt. Eine Sache vielleicht noch zu Go, die mir noch einfällt, die ich auch wichtig finde, womit sie interessanterweise nicht so gewädelt und gerodert haben, ist jetzt mit irgendwie, wir sind objektorientiert.
Sind so oder sind sie nicht?
Ich habe nichts gehört von Objekten. Aber sie haben was anderes Interessantes. Es gibt auch andere populäre Sprachen, die nicht unbedingt objektorientiert sind. Sie haben aber ein starkes Typ-System. Das heißt, sie sind stark typisiert. Sie haben auch diesen Scheiß da mit C quasi so weit verlassen, als dass halt auch alle Base-Types irgendwie richtige Typen sind. Und nicht irgendwelche Bites oder so. Ich muss kurz nochmal nachdenken. Du kannst halt deine Typen und deine Methoden definieren und du definierst halt deine Methoden auf Typen, aber sie sind halt nicht Teil von Objektklassen oder so. Das ist ja auch etwas, was ich immer gerne kritisiere, so bei anderen Programmiersprachen. Ich halte das einfach für Unfug. Das machen sie halt nicht, aber allein schon deshalb, weil sie gar keine Klassen haben. Aber sie definieren halt Polymorphie explizit, also Polymorphie im Sinne von, wenn du eine Methode hast, die mit dem einen Objektyp das eine tut, dann möchtest du halt eigentlich eine Methode gleichen Namens auch auf irgendwas anderes anwenden und erwartest, dass da auch eine ähnliche Funktionalität herauskommt. Und du kannst bei Google Go Interfaces definieren, die jetzt nicht so gemeint sind, wie die Interfaces bei Java. Bei Java sind es ja eher so ein Versprechen, die dann der Programmierer einhalten muss. Bei Go kannst du damit sozusagen explizit dem Compiler annuncen. Das verhält sich genauso wie das bei dem Objekt. Da endet jetzt so ein bisschen mein Basiswissen. Ich gebe jetzt hier nur einen Überblick wieder. Sodass du eben Polymorphie quasi da auch auf Sprachebene deklarieren kannst. So, das halte ich einfach schonmal für ein relativ starkes Konzept in einer Programmiersprache, auf dem man bestimmt ganz ordentliche Strukturen aufbauen kann. So, und das ist auch schon das Ende meiner gefühlten Geschichte. Also gefühlt finde ich das einfach interessant. Ich würde jetzt nicht Go als die Antwort auf alle Fragen der Programmierung nennen, aber sie machen halt ein interessantes neues Tor auf durch diese Konzentration auf Performance im Hinblick auf Turnaround-Zeit beim entwickeln und auf Parallelisierung. Das ist schon ein echter Klopfer. Im Chat meint einer, im Chat meint noch einer, das objektorientiert und performanceig beißt. Das ist gelinde gesagt.
Quatsch.
Neues Thema?
Ja.
Das ist jetzt super schön, dass es so bekannt ist, diese, um ein neues Thema zu gehen. Ein noch nicht-Google-Thema.
Nee, aber so ähnlich.
Wie hieß noch gleich die andere Webseite?
Ja, unser allergeliebter im Microblogging-Dienst hat neue Features.
Ja, mal sehen, wie lange ich die noch so liebe.
Zu welcher Fraktion gehörst du denn?
Was Retweets angeht?
Du bist ja so ein Fix-It-Baby-Anhänger.
Ich finde die Retweets so... Also passen wir kurz zusammen.
Twitter hat drei neue Features. Listen, Retweets und Geolocation.
Genau. Fangen wir mit Retweets an. Ich finde, Twitter hat damit wirklich so richtig schön ins Klo gegriffen. Das ist so das Dämlichste, was man machen kann.
Das ist geil, Max. Was war das, was ich glaube? Ich halte das für einen ganz großen Wurf.
Ernsthaft?
Doch, ich finde das richtig cool. Das ist genau das, was ich wollte, dass sie es tun. Max macht hier gerade die Matrix-Haltbewegung. Warum ich das denke? Ja, also erstens, Retweets bisher sind die pein. Also wenn ich da mal was halbwegs populäres, die Massen mobilisierendes schreibe, dann gehe ich unter in einem Gewitter von Menschen, die irgendwie irgendwelche verstümmelten Teilaspekte meines Tweets haben, wo dann irgendwie dann auch noch im 2. und 3. und 4. Level irgendwie RT ich, irgendwie RT noch eine Person, bis von meinem Tweet irgendwie noch 5 Buchstaben übrig sind. Oder dass Leute mich nicht retweeten, weil ich magisch mal wieder die 140 Zeichen ausgenutzt habe und sie nicht in der Lage sind, den Inhalt meines Tweets wiederzugeben, wenn sie auch nur ein Wort kürzen, was dann auch noch in Abhängigkeit meiner Twitter-User-Namenlänge ist.
Weil die noch relativ groß ist bei dir.
Ja, und dann kommt noch einer, der mich retweetet hat, den jemand anders retweetet. So geht es einfach schon mal gar nicht. Und was sie jetzt eigentlich gemacht haben, ist, dass sie Retweet einfach als System-Feature machen. Und wenn du etwas retweetest, dann heißt das, dass du das, was ich gesagt habe, als mich selbst in deren Timeline werfen. Das heißt, folge ich Person X, und Person X folgt Person Y, und diese Person Y sagt jetzt was Tolles, und X retweetet das. Dann kriege ich das halt zu sehen von Y, obwohl ich normalerweise Y nicht auf meiner Timeline habe. Daran stören sich Leute, und das kann ich ehrlich gesagt nicht verstehen, weil das ist genau das, was man will. Ich sehe ja, das ist ja jemand, den ich nicht kenne, aber der wird da jetzt sozusagen auftauchen, also ist er retweetet worden. Außerdem steht es ja dabei, dass er retweetet wurde und auch von wem. Von daher geht gar keine Information verloren, aber ich habe die volle Metainformation des Retweetens.
Das ist auch nicht meine Hauptkritik.
Du willst Kommentare haben?
Ich will Redundanz haben. Was bei den Retweets wirklich total scheiße ist, wenn ich jetzt, nehmen wir mal einen, ich würde jetzt bei einer Timeline von gestern Abend durchgehen und würde feststellen, Menschenskinder, der Tim, der hat ja gestern Abend was getwittert, was total interessant war, ich retweete das jetzt mal und klicke auf den Retweet-Button. Dann sehen Leute, die mir followen, das ist in ihrer Timeline. Und zwar an welcher Stelle sehen sie es in ihrer Timeline? Nein, gestern Abend, als du es getwittert hast. Mit anderen Worten, wenn ich das jetzt machen würde, würde das keine Sau mehr sehen. Das ist... Es wird an der Stelle an deiner Timeline einsortiert, nicht zu dem Zeitpunkt, zu dem es retweeted wurde, sondern...
Sondern, wann es getweetet wurde.
Sondern es getweetet wurde, genau.
Auf der Twitter-Homepage?
Ja, oder beziehungsweise in der API wird es auch so einsortiert.
Was heißt das, es wird so einsortiert? Der Event muss doch in dem Moment dann...
Nee, das ist ganz hinten. Das ist, Leute, ich hab sechs Stunden alte Tweets retweeted. Und dann hat mich jemand gefragt, hast du das vor sechs Stunden retweeted? Oder eben gerade? Ich hab gesagt, eben gerade. Bei mir in der Timeline vor sechs Stunden drinne. Das ist ein reiner Zufall, dass er das überhaupt mitbekommen hat. Das heißt also, die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass man so einen Retweet sieht, sinkt massiv, je älter der Original-Tweet ist.
Du meinst, wenn dann ein Twitter-Client meine Timeline holt und da sind irgendwie retweetete Sachen drin, dass sie dann nicht auftauchen, auch wenn sie vor zehn Minuten retweeted wurden, weil sie schon älter sind als mein Client überhaupt nachfragt?
Genau.
Oh, das wusste ich noch gar nicht.
Find ich total dämlich. Wozu mach ich mir Arbeit, jetzt das zu retweeten, wenn ich's...
Warum machen Sie das? Ich würde sagen, guten Grund für. Das Problem ist, ich benutze ja Twitter nicht über die Webseite. Deswegen kann ich das derzeit noch gar nicht so richtig erfahren. Ich warte darauf, dass halt die ersten Twitter-Clients kommen, die Retweeting unterstützen.
Gibt es schon noch einen? Boxcar unterstützt es offensichtlich, aber nur für die Notifications. Ansonsten kenne ich noch keinen. Boxcar ist für das iPhone so eine App, dass man, wenn man eine Menschen oder eine Direct Message hat, dass man die wie so eine SMS gepusht bekommt. So ein Push-Client für. Tweety? Gibt es eine Beta-Version, die das kann? Wo gibt es die?
Die 2.1, die soll jetzt irgendwie demnächst mal kommen, wurde gesagt. Aber ich weiß nicht, wie man die Beta sich auf dem...... machen kann. Ich hoffe, vorne soll es auch schon können auf dem Mac.
Das finde ich das eine, doofe Features an Retweets. Das zweite, was ich eher nachteilig finde, ist... Retweets sind Redundanz. Und ich halte Redundanz bis zu einem gewissen Grad für wichtig. Also wenn ich so durch meine Timeline durchgehe, dann ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass ich ein Thema...... beim ersten Mal übersehe, sehr, sehr hoch. Wenn es dann aber der zweite und der dritte und der vierte...... nochmal retweetet und ich das dann sehe, dann kriege ich irgendwann mit, Moment mal, das ist vielleicht doch ein spannendes Thema.
Gut, aber das ist ja im Prinzip dasselbe Argument noch. Also die stört sozusagen nicht, dass es sich dann nicht akkumuliert.
Genau, ich möchte tatsächlich mehrfach darauf hingewiesen werden. Es wäre natürlich geil, wenn ich dann so ein Button hätte, so, ja, jetzt habe ich es verstanden, jetzt brauchst du es mir nicht mehr anzuzeigen oder sowas. Es ist einfach der ganze Lärm, den man durch Retweets macht bei Twitter. Total reduziert auf 1, plus 1, plus 1, plus 1.
Das mit dieser Zeit, das war mir irgendwie noch nicht so ganz klar. Ich habe jetzt mal hier kurz die aktuelle Echo-Phone-Version, die ich schon auf einer Platte hat, aber nicht benutze. Ach so, dieses Standalone-App? Das zeigt mir tatsächlich hier Retweets an. Jetzt kann ich natürlich nicht sehen, wie das hier so vom Zeitverlauf war, aber ich sehe halt jetzt hier das hier etwas. Genau, das habe ich nämlich in meiner Timeline, den ich normalerweise da nicht habe, aber weil jemand, den ich in meiner Liste habe, das retweetet hat, ist das hier. Und das ist dann auch so markiert mit wurde retweetet von. Taucht aber jetzt als vorletzten Eintrag auf, obwohl es two hours ago ist. Das würde ja jetzt sozusagen deinem Punkt widersprechen.
Vielleicht haben sie es ja irgendwie nochmal...
Also es ist zwar markiert, dass es zwei Stunden alt ist, aber es taucht als vorletzter Eintrag auf. Und das ist eigentlich genau das, wie ich mir das denke. Ich sehe, dass das alt ist. Ich sehe, dass das retweetet ist, aber es wird mir trotzdem vor die Nase gehalten. Vielleicht haben sie es verbessert. Vielleicht hast du auch das Feature nicht ganz verstanden. Weil die Zeit ist natürlich schon die Zeit des Tweets. Ist ja auch klar, weil das will ich ja auch wissen. Ich will auch wissen, und wenn das alt ist. Die Frage ist nur, ob der Kleine in der Lage ist, es quasi von dem Retweet-Zeitpunkt her einzusortieren. Und das geht offensichtlich. Weil hier ist irgendwie vier Minuten vor vier Minuten, vor zwei Stunden, vor zwei Minuten. Und von daher müsste ich deiner Aussage etwas widersprechen.
Okay, dann habe ich mich damit...
Zumindest ist es bei Echo-Phonen so, ne?
Vielleicht sortieren die es einfach anders ein. Vielleicht haben sie es auch mittlerweile gebessert. Es haben sich Leute bitterlich bei mir beschwert. Ich selber habe es noch gar nicht überprüft gehabt.
Tja, ich muss sagen, das ist so, wie ich es mir wünsche. Jetzt sehe ich Retweets als solche. Es geht nichts mehr verloren. Ich habe die volle Metadata-Geschichte. Es werden keine URLs irgendwie zerstört. Es werden keine Texte gekürzt. Ich weiß, wer es retweetet hat. Ich weiß, wer retweetet wurde. Es ist mir egal, ob das über fünf Ecken gegangen ist, weil das ist für mich die totale Null-Information. Dieses RT-User, RT-User, lalalala. Das will man einfach alles nicht haben. Und so taucht das ja offensichtlich nochmal auf. Man ist die Frage, wenn jetzt dieser Tweet, den ich jetzt hier sehe, nochmal... Ja, doch, müsste eigentlich nochmal auftauchen. Also wir stellen fest, wir wissen es nicht 100%ig. Also ich finde, dass ein erster Test zeigt, es könnte so oder so sein.
Dass es eine Retweet-Art bekommt, fand ich gut, weil ich habe ich sehr unterstützt. Genau mit den Kürzungsgründen und sowas, diese Problematik. Und ich finde auch, dass man das Originalbild von der Person, die es tatsächlich getweetet hat und zusätzlich nochmal das Bild von der Person, die es retweetet hat, ist auch eine wichtige Information.
Hier taucht jetzt kein Bild auf, aber das könnte man natürlich auch so machen.
Finde ich auch gut, aber ich finde eben, dass das Redundanz so gekillt wird, finde ich nicht schön. Ich finde es...
Ich stelle gerade fest, dass Echo Phone für einen Mac besser geworden ist.
Das hatte ich eben gerade auch gedacht. Echo Phone ist echt geil geworden.
Ich habe das ja irgendwie am Anfang nicht für... Ich habe das nicht ganz ernst genommen, aber jetzt könnte ich mir glatt vorstellen, mal umzusteigen. Wieder mal.
Genau, das war der gleiche Gedanke, den ich gerade auch hatte.
Weil die Suche benutze ich nicht so häufig. Aber wie ist das mit mehreren Accounts?
Mehrere Accounts scheinen kein Problem zu sein.
Scheinen kein Problem zu sein. Die Frage ist, wie wird es dargestellt? Okay, das können wir nachher prüfen. Tja, ich hoffe, unten ist noch im Rennen.
So viel steht schon mal fest.
So, haben wir das Thema irgendwie Retweets jetzt bearbeitet?
Retweets haben wir bearbeitet. Und was haben wir noch?
Listen.
Listen finde ich...
Egal.
Obwohl, nee, finde ich gar nicht so egal.
Also ist so ein bisschen auch die Antwort auf diesen Follow Friday. Weil auch dieses permanente Empfehlen von Leuten, es gab bisher keine andere Möglichkeit, als das explizit in Tweets zu tun. Und ich muss sagen, obwohl ich das durchaus schätze, wenn man da selber empfohlen wird, oder ab und zu auch mal mir das mal anschaue, aber das ist für mich nicht wirklich so richtig eine Quelle, neue Leute zu finden, diese followfreie Geschichte. Das ist mehr so eine Credibility-Verstärkung.
Blah, so.
Wenn man da jemanden liest, dem man selber folgt, der häufiger getweetet wird, aber man liest es ja eh nur bei Leuten, denen man folgt, das ist irgendwie alles, und diese Listen stellen das halt in einen Kontext. Weil es ja auch so ist, du kannst ja niemanden in deinen Listen haben, dem du nicht selber folgst. Und an der Stelle finde ich das relativ...
Was?
Ja, ja, das geht. Ich hab nämlich das sehr lustig.
Wie ernsthaft? Ich dachte, wieso...
Du hast mich verwirrt.
Ich dachte, ich wähle das in meiner Follower-Liste auf.
Nee, du kannst den auch so in den Listen packen. Ich hab nämlich...
Meinst du, ich kann dich auch in eine Liste nehmen? Wie folge ich denn nicht? Ah, ich weiß, wie ich mich gerade nicht folge. Mal gucken, ob ich dem jetzt irgendwie eine Liste geben kann.
Die einzige Liste, die ich überhaupt habe, die ich nutze, kann man jetzt auch nachgucken. Insofern kann ich dir den Namen sagen, ist auch eher ein Gag. UR mit drei R's. Der hat nämlich eine Liste angelegt, Leute, die ich nicht mag. Die sind so 300 Leute drinne, unter anderem ich. Daraufhin hab ich eine Liste angelegt, mit dem Namen ich dich auch nicht. Und da ist nur er drinne. Und ich folge ihm aus der Liste. Er hat's mitbekommen, das ist ja lustig.
Ich hab tatsächlich einfach nur Quatsch erzählt. Ich kann auch Leute, denen ich nicht folgen, auf Listen nehmen. Aber sieht man dann das?
Es ist teilweise ganz lustig zu sehen, in welchen...
Man kann ja dem Listennamen ansehen, ob das eine Empfehlung ist oder nicht. Und von daher erfüllt es eben eine ähnliche Geschichte. Die Frage ist, ob man die auch genauso wahrnimmt. Ich weiß gar nicht, in was für Listen ich bin. Soll ich mal gucken?
Guck mir das manchmal so an. Also, was offensichtlich gerade mal wieder was automatisch erzeugt ist, dürfte Conversation-List sein. A dynamic list rebuild daily of the people you are talking to and about.
Ach, sowas gibt es auch?
Jaja, es gibt ja... Keine Ahnung.
Es gibt ja...
Es gibt ja die MyFafstarFM-List. Das ist so eine Liste, die von Fafstar dir eingerichtet wird, wenn du magst. Also das sind Leute, die...
Conversation-List, achja. Achso, ja, aber wer legt denn diese Conversation-List an?
Das wird dann irgendein App sein. Mal sehen, ob sich... weißt das irgendjemand?
Achso, das ist...
ok, verstehe.
Conversation-List. Also ich bin in relativ langweiligen Listen. Ich bin in Conversation-Lists, auch mit Leuten, die ich gar nicht kenne. Also wie können die mit mir in einer Conversation sein, wenn ich die gar nicht kenne?
Warte mal, irgendwo stand eine Erklärung darüber, das sind einfach nur... To and about.
Ah ok, gut, dann mag das Leute, die über mich reden, aber nicht unbedingt mit denen, mit denen ich rede, also denen ich nichts geschrieben habe.
Ui, ich bin an meiner Liste deutsche Twitter-Poeten drinnen.
Ich bin in so... ich bin in so ganz komischen... Ich bin in langweiligen Listen-Namen drin, das nervt mich. Philosophie, das ist ja noch halbwegs.
Einmal bin ich in der Liste, geht euch einen Scheißdreck an.
Potenzielle Gefährder. Ich bin in einer Liste Potenzielle Gefährder. Das ist ja mal ein Kompliment.
Also ich finde bisher eigentlich immer ganz schick, dass man bei Twitter keine Listen anlegen muss. Jetzt kann man es, wenn man es mag. Man kann das Feature aber auch sehr schön ignorieren.
Ja, man kann das auch ignorieren. Und man kann ja auch Listen folgen. Das tue ich auch nicht.
Ja, mache ich bisher auch tatsächlich gar nicht.
Aber ich könnte mir durchaus vorstellen, dass das noch kommt. Weil das ist ja nur noch ein neues Feature. Und manchmal ist es ein bisschen nerviger. Wenn man zum Beispiel so einem Projekt vorübergehend folgen möchte und im Sinne von all den Leuten in diesem Projekt, dann willst du nicht die Einzelnen alle folgen. Aber du willst vielleicht mal der Projektliste, also Projekt-Member-Liste folgen für diesen Zeitraum. Das weiß ich angenommen. Du machst wieder so eine wilde Wir-laufen-durch-die-Stadt- und-alle-gucken-zu-Nummer. Und dann irgendwie mit mehreren Accounts, die dann irgendwie unterschiedliche Dinge tun und tweeten. Und denen willst du dann halt mal folgen. Aber du willst auch wissen, du kannst dann am Montag, wenn der ganze Scheiß vorbei ist, auch einen definierten Cleanup machen, indem du dann halt dieser Liste nicht mehr folgst.
Das könnte so ein bisschen die Hashtags ersetzen, oder?
Dass man...
Oder einen Moderator zum Beispiel.
Welchen Hashtag? Ich meine, das sind ja keine Themen, sondern Leute.
Naja, du könntest aber zum Beispiel, was weiß ich, wenn jetzt hier der Kongress stattfindet, dann könnte man das so machen, also bisher würde man das so machen, dass man da den Hashtag 26c3 hinten dran hängt. Und dann müsste ich was ja sowieso ein bisschen doof ist, dass man Hashtags nicht sowieso folgen kann.
Der User 26c3 könnte sich eine Liste Services machen. Da ist dann das POC drin und so weiter.
Na der könnte auch eine Liste machen, in die man sich irgendwie einen Public Interface, wo man sich eintragen kann, hey, ich bin Besucher 26c3. Und dann könnte man für die Zeit dieser Liste followen. Und hätte dann alles zu dem Thema in seiner Timeline drin. Ohne, dass man jedes Mal dazuschreiben muss, explizit einen Hashtag und weiß nicht toll, was. Und wenn der ganze Spaß vorbei ist, dann klicke ich wieder auf unfollow und dann unterstimmlich die Leute auch wieder nicht mehr.
Ja, also es gibt da sicherlich Anwendungen dafür. Ich finde Listen also nicht störend und eine schöne Erweiterung und da kann man leben. Und womit ich auch nichts anfangen kann, was ich aber auch schön finde, dass es dabei ist, ist diese Geo-Geschichte.
Geo-Geschichte, glaube ich, ist das Brüller-Feature.
Wirklich?
Ja.
Dann müsste ich das ja einschalten an meinem Client.
Dann müsstest du das einschalten an deinem Client. Hast du es mal mit Birdfeed ausprobiert? Nö.
Ich muss zugeben, ich bin ja an sich schon ein bisschen rampensauermäßig veranlagt, aber dieses permanent meinen Ort mitführen Ding, da es erreicht bei mir so eine Grenze.
Also, bei Birdfeed ist es ja genauso, dass du eben nicht jedes Mal, sondern hast oben eine kleine Leiste drüber.
Klar.
Und auf die musst du drauf tippen, wenn du deine Location mit durchgehen willst.
Ja, also richtig sinnvoll ist es eigentlich nur, wenn du das immer benutzt. Nö. Was mir fehlt in diesen Clients ist, ich hätte ganz gerne vielleicht gibt's das ja, vielleicht kannst du mir das sagen. Also, ich würde das vielleicht benutzen, wenn ich sagen kann, wie viele Nachkommastellen der GPS-Koordinate er weglässt. Oder beziehungsweise er behält. Also, ich würde meine Geo-Koordinaten gerne freigeben, aber nur auf zwei Nachkommastellen. Aber nicht auf vier oder fünf.
Ich glaube, das kann man bisher bei keinem.
Ja, aber du weißt, dass... Also, ich will sozusagen...
Du möchtest es unscharfer haben.
Ich gebe gerne zur Kenntnis, dass ich in Berlin bin und vielleicht auch ob ich im Osten oder im Westen bin. Aber mehr muss jetzt nicht interessieren. Gerade für so Umgebungstweets ist es drin. Und kann diese Geo... Hast du die GOP angeschaut?
So ein bisschen.
Kann man da quasi eine Genauigkeit mit angeben? Also kann ich sagen, ob ich nun einen Punkt meine oder ob ich einen Bereich meine? Das ist jetzt plus, minus 10 Kilometer.
Also es ist eigentlich relativ üblich, dass man sowas hat. Schon allein weil ja die Clients dich eventuell nicht so genau positionieren.
Ich weiß aber nicht, ob es bei Twitter drin ist.
Aber ich weiß es tatsächlich auch nicht. Das wäre mal eine interessante Frage.
Das wäre sehr schade, wenn sie das weggelassen haben.
Nee, also wofür ich glaube, dass das Brüller-Feature sein wird, ist eben, also es gibt ja, ich weiß nicht, kennst du Foursquare?
Ich habe davon gehört.
Also ich habe es eine Zeit lang ausprobiert. Vom Ansatz her, was macht das? Das ist, dass der Gedanke ist, also eigentlich ist das das erste iPhone-App für Alkoholiker. Das erste Social-App für Alkoholiker. Das ist, wenn du in irgendeiner Kneipe bist oder in einem Café, gehst du, sagst du, ich bin gerade in dem Café und dann kriegen alle deine Freunde eine Notification darüber, per Push auf ein iPhone, der ist jetzt gerade da und da. Das haben die noch ein bisschen aufgehübscht, dass wenn du in New York bist, also wenn du die Person bist, die am häufigsten sich in einer Kneipe eingeloggt hat oder in einem Café, bist du ja sogenannte Major, Major, Major, ich weiß nicht, wie das ausgesprochen wird, der Bürgermeister. Und die haben Deals mit den Kneipen, dass du als Major dann zum Beispiel, also ich sehe Baso, der hat im Oberholz eine Café-Flatrate.
Ach so, weil er Bürgermeister ist?
Genau. Und dadurch betteln sich die Leute dann natürlich richtig schön teilweise und wollen dann immer ganz weit vorne sein, weil du hast durchaus was davon unter Umständen.
Warte mal, wodurch wird man Bürgermeister?
Dass man sich am häufigsten da einloggt.
Ah, einfach da sein?
Einfach da sein. Und dadurch...
Gibt es da auch eine iPhone-Abführ?
Ja, da gibt es eine iPhone-Abführ. Die funktioniert allerdings nur so... Also ich hab sie wieder gelöscht, weil ich krieg total unwesentliche Informationen darüber mitgeteilt. Was ich gerne hätte, wäre ein Feature, zum Beispiel... Ja, sag mir Bescheid, wenn da ein Umkreis von zwei Kilometern ist oder sowas, wo ich auch in Zweifelsfall mit hinkommen könnte. Mich interessiert das nicht, dass jetzt irgendjemand gerade irgendwo in Charlottenburg ein Café betreten hat. Das ist mir total stulle. Oder noch besser, sag...
Jemand, den du kennst?
Jemand, den ich kenne.
Das ist für dich irrelevant?
Ob jemand, der sowieso die ganze Zeit in Berlin ist, ob der jetzt 10 Kilometer in einem Café in Mitte ist oder in Wedding oder weißt du was, wo, ist für mich tatsächlich relativ... Also das ist eine Information, wo ich unter Umständen nachgucken möchte, aber möchte ich keine Push-Notification drüber haben. Was ich aber spannend finden würde, wäre zum Beispiel, ich hab da mir ein paar Gedanken drüber gemacht, wenn jetzt eine Position, die relativ zu ihren normalen Tweets näher ist, also wenn zum Beispiel eine Person, die aus München kommt, der ich folge zum Beispiel auf Twitter, wenn die plötzlich mal aus Berlin ein paar Tweets absetzt, dann ist das sicherlich auch eine interessante Information, wenn die nur 10 Kilometer entfernt ist.
Das ist so wie dieser, wie dieser, wie dieser, was war das noch gleich? Ein Gefühl, ein Geräusch, was man im Panathelitischen Galaxis gibt so ein, die Aussage, dass jeder, jedes Lebewesen einen, so ein, ist das eine Welle, so eine Abstrahlung, also irgendwie so etwas aussendet, was stärker wird, umso weiter du von deinem Heimatort entfernt bist, was auf der Erde nicht auffällt, weil man ja nur, immer nur so 10, 20, 50.000 Kilometer von seinem Heimatort entfernt ist, aber es erst nach ein paar Millionen Kilometern wirklich interessant wird, so. Und das führt dann immer dazu, dass Leute so ein gewisses Unwohlsein empfinden, wenn sie irgendwie Fort Prefect begegnen.
So was meinst du im Prinzip, so ein, so ein...
Genau so was.
Dass dein iPhone anfängt zu vibrieren.
Ja.
So, Person, die von sehr weit weg kommt, kommt dir näher.
Naja, also jetzt nicht um das Unwohlseinswille, sondern...
Naja, gut, es muss ja jetzt nicht unwohl sein.
Es ist genau um das Gegenteil Willens, um das...
Einfach ums zu merken.
Ums zu merken, genau.
Something is different now.
Und darüber hinaus kann natürlich noch dieses, dieses Location-ARP eben, also so, so, so eine Regionalisierung oder Lokalisierung von Tweets hatte ich für unglaublich spannend. Also zum einen für Nachrichten, für irgendwelche News. Also mich wundert das, warum das noch niemand gemacht hat. So bei diesem, bei diesem iPhone, wenn du ein iPhone, ein Foto machst und das irgendwie auf eine Seite postest, dann bleibt dir da gerne die Gear-Location drin. Das heißt, Twittpick hat ungefähr Fotos von einer halben Welt. Wenn irgendwo gerade was passiert, könnte Twittpick eigentlich auf der Stelle hingehen. Du kommst hin, hast eine Google-Map, nimmst ein Werkzeug, ziehst darüber einen Kreis auf über der Region, die dich interessiert und kriegst alle Fotos angezeigt, die da reingehen. Das ist für eine Nachrichtenagentur ist das natürlich spannend wie Sau.
Sozusagen in Realtime.
In Realtime. Das gleiche kannst du dann plötzlich mit Tweets machen. Du bist auf irgendeiner Demo.
Das ist fast noch interessanter, oder?
Mit Bildern ist fast noch interessanter. Kann man das machen bei Twittpick?
Kann man da irgendwie so einen Stream abonnieren?
Nein, das geht eben nicht. Mich wundert, warum sie das nicht tun. Sie haben die Informationen vorliegen.
Das ist eine geile Idee, vor allem wenn du so eine Applikation hast, was weiß ich, Google Earth.
Das wäre eine Geschäftsapplikation für Twittpick. Für Nachrichtsagenturen sowas zu verdecken. Stimmt.
Das sagen wir aber jetzt calm.
Das sagen wir jetzt calm.
Das sagen wir jetzt reich mit.
Insofern finde ich, diese Geolocation-AP könnte ein absoluter Killerfeature sein.
Wo du dieses Foursquare erwähnst, was ähnlich ist, ist ja dieses Go-Ovala.
Genau, das geht auch ein bisschen in die Richtung.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, wie weit sich das jetzt von den Foursquare unterscheidet. Bürgermeister scheint es da nicht zu geben. Kommt aber auch so mit Push daher. Ich habe es jetzt mal ein bisschen ausprobiert, um nach einem Tag festzustellen, dass sie dann automatisch im Web dokumentieren, wo man sich überall eingecheckt hat, ohne dass du das ausschalten kannst. Also ich habe ja kein Problem damit, so eine Information mit Freunden zu scheren, aber ich will halt nicht das by default vor Public haben.
Ist das bei Foursquare auch so? Weiß ich ehrlich gesagt nicht.
Bei Lettitude von Google ist es relativ angeschränkt. Ich kriege jetzt immer mal wieder irgendwelche Request von Leuten und so weiter. Ihr braucht es erst gar nicht zu probieren. Ich bin da sehr zurückhaltend, was meine Geolocation betrifft. Es gibt ein paar Leute, mit denen ich da so rum experimentiere.
Aber das überzeugt mich alles noch nicht. Mich hat auch jemand gefragt, der nicht mal seinen vollen Namen, sondern nur seine Initialen hingeschrieben hat. Mir nicht deinen Namen sagen wollen, aber meine Location haben wollen? Ich glaube eher nicht.
So wird das nichts, Leute. So wird das nichts. Wollen wir mal jetzt nach einer 1,5 Stunde vielleicht dann auch mal den Themenbereich vorstoßen, für die dieser Podcast sich eigentlich Willkommen bei Google, mobile Google.
Gut, ja, machen wir mal weiter.
Du blickst gerade voller Entsetzen auf die Notiz, die ich da gemacht habe und du fragst dich, was ist jetzt schon wieder los?
Genau.
Das Internet und Vergrößerungen.
Eine Geschichte voller Geheimnis und Missverständnisse.
Man kann das Wort groß nicht schreiben, ohne dass man an Spam denkt.
Das ist echt krass.
Ja, ich weiß gar nicht, warum ich das aufgeschrieben habe. Ich glaube, weil ich neulich bei so einem Hörertreffen mal die Diskussion hatte. Große Mauscursor können glücklich machen.
Tim hat immer einen extrem großen Mauscursor.
Ja, genau. Also was wenige wissen, man kann auf dem Mac einfach in den Accessibility-Settings seine Mauscursor-Größe vergrößern.
Aber nicht so schön wie bei anderen Betriebssystemen.
Nicht so schön wie bei welchen anderen Desktop-Betriebssystemen?
Oh, bunte oder Windows?
Ja, weil die dann auch hübsch aussehen.
Die sehen auch nachdem sie skaliert sind doch gut aus.
Ja, das ist furchtbar, oder? Ich verstehe überhaupt nicht, warum sie das machen. Ich meine, jetzt haben sie da so in your face diese Option reingebaut und sie skalieren dann tatsächlich diesen Mini-Pixel-Cursor einfach die Pixel groß, anstatt einen größeren Sprite zu nehmen.
Eikens können mittlerweile so vier Bildschirme groß sein.
Ja, aber einen Maus-Cursor nicht. Da frage ich mich doch jetzt ernsthaft, ob es da irgendeinen Grund für gibt. Also es gibt bestimmt einen Grund, aber ich glaube der Grund ist eher so was, we didn't think about it oder so.
Ja, ich glaube, das wird auch der Grund sein. Das ist übrigens auch der Grund, warum mein Maus-Cursor so default klein ist, weil ich nämlich das Gefühl habe, sonst nicht mehr haargenau zu wissen, wo ich gerade hin klicke, wenn ich...
Das ist übrigens ein interessanter Punkt, weil ich benutze einfach größeren Maus-Cursor, damit ich das Ding einfach immer finde. Und ich habe festgestellt, dass es für mich jetzt erstmal für das normale Arbeiten keine Einschränkung bedeutet. Das gilt für die meisten Maus-Cursor. Es gibt allerdings sowas wie den Text-Insert-Marker, den ich sowieso schon nicht besonders spezifisch finde, aber der wird dann irgendwie verwirrend.
So Fotoshops, so Crosshair-Cursor und sowas, die gehen dann richtig ab.
Na, wenn die immer noch auf die richtige Stelle zeigen.
Na ja, aber die sind ja pixelgenau gemacht. Und wenn du dann plötzlich der Crosshair da drinnen 4x4 pixelgroß ist, dann...
Das ist natürlich ein Argument. Deswegen ist das ja auch nur eine Hilfe. Ich hab's dann komischerweise auf dem iMac wieder abgeschaltet, weil ich irgendwie, kurioserweise, den Eindruck hatte, dass es meine Treffgenauigkeit beeinflusst hat. Was ich auf meinem MacBook allerdings nie hatte.
Auf dem iMac hast du es?
Ja, mit der Maus hat es mir Probleme bereitet, wo es mit dem Trackpad irgendwie unproblematisch war. Ich hab da keine wirkliche Theorie dafür. Aber vielleicht wollt ihr das einfach mal machen. Ich hab von Leuten gehört, die haben das eingeschaltet und waren danach glücklicher. Und haben sich gefragt, warum sie das nicht schon häufiger gemacht haben.
Das ist in der Bedienungshilfe. Das ist so dieses... Das ist die Einstellung drinnen. Da sind überhaupt einen Haufen Einstellungen drinnen, die total toll sind, in die man so nicht denkt. Ach nee, da ist das nicht. Wo ist denn die Größe? Ach doch, da. Maus und Trackpad und da Cursor-Größe. Genau, da stellt man die ein und dann kann man die gnadenlos größer und kleiner machen. Ich finde da auch eine Option sehr schön, die da drin ist und zwar unter dem Hören-Tab, dass der Bildschirm blinken lassen, wenn der Warnton er tönt.
Bildschirm blinken lassen?
Dann blinkt es sowieso weiß auf und dann wird er so kurz weiß, was erstens sehr geil aussieht und zweitens ist es, wenn man den Ton abgeschaltet hat, weil man in einer Büroumgebung ist oder gerade einen Podcast macht, verliert man das Feedback nicht. Dann verliert man das, genau, kriegt man das mit weiterhin. Das ist echt eine schöne Sache.
Das ist auch schöner als irgendwie diese... Ich meine, es gibt ja Leute, die haben ja auch wirklich merkwürdige Warentöne eingestellt.
Und weiß auf schwarz lohnt sich einfach mal einzustellen, damit man denkt, wow!
Ja, vielleicht mal sollten wir mal ein bisschen über unser 10.6.2-Update reden.
Das ist jetzt aber schon länger her, oder? Ich weiß gar nicht, was immer passiert.
Wir sind kein aktueller Podcast.
Ach so, stimmt.
Wir sind schon wieder jetzt drei Wochen. Die Jungs in München, die sitzen da jede Woche und knechten sich wirklich durch jedes Gerücht in diesem Internet. Und wir, was machen wir?
Ich hab jetzt gerade das Update auf System 7.1 gemacht.
Dann kommt die Hälfte nicht. Und dann irgendwie, ja, das ist jetzt auch alles nicht so interessant. Und dann unterhalten wir es über große Maus-Cursor. So muss man erstmal so viel Mummus aufbringen. Aber ich hab ja wieder so eine persönliche Geschichte zu erzählen, deswegen hab ich das mit dem 10.6.2-Update dahingemacht, weil da wurde mir erstmal wieder klar, wie wichtig dieses Update war. Ich hatte nämlich hier ein Problem, das jetzt, wie ich hoffe, weg ist. Das Problem ist, dass was war nochmal gleich das Problem? Das Problem war, dass mein Rechner furchtbar langsam wurde. Das ist ein Prozess, der hat vor drei Wochen angefangen. Weißt du so, als ob du im Morast sitzt und irgendwie Gummi an einem klebt. Alles wird langsam, du klickst auf irgendwas und es dauert 5 oder 10 Sekunden, bis das Programm nach vorne kommt und alles freest bis hin zum Maus-Cursor. Wenn der Maus-Cursor freest auf dem Mac, dann weiß ich, da ist die Kacke irgendwie am dampfen. Und es gibt zwei Möglichkeiten, dass es sein kann.
Weil ich doch dieses Problem hier mit der SATA 2-Festplatte hatte, die nach wie vor nicht so hundertprozentig gelöst ist auf dem Mac. So füllt sich das an.
Ja, und was hast du da für Effekte?
Programme, die ewig lange brauchen, bis sie nach vorne kommen. Teilweise, dass das Maus-Cursor-Bewegen nichts mehr bringt. Maus-Cursor stehen hatte ich tatsächlich, glaube ich, so gut wie nie. Immer so ein paar Sekunden zwischendurch.
Aber das Problem war doch...
Gerne, wenn der RAM-Rand voll ist.
Aber das Problem wurde doch adressiert.
Na ja, es hat ein bisschen was gebracht. Aber so hundertprozentig ist das immer noch nicht weg. Also es tritt gerne auf. Ich hab das Gefühl, wenn der RAM voll ist und man... Also wenn man irgendwie ein Programm startet, das extrem viel... Also ich hab das jetzt mit Paradells ständig. Also wenn man zwar das Betriebssystem innerhalb seines ersten Betriebssystems aufmacht, dann wird der Rechner danach langsam und gewöhnt sich das auch nur sehr, sehr schwer wieder ab. Beziehungsweise dann tatsächlich oh mein Gott, nur nach einem Neustart.
Also genau, jetzt wird's doch noch interessanter, als ich dachte, als ich den Punkt aufgeschrieben habe, weil ich hatte nun wirklich eben diese Effekte und ich muss sagen, ich hatte jetzt dein SATA-Problem, das hast du noch nicht mal geschildert, aber ich glaube, ich hab noch mit einem Ohr zugehört. Und ich hatte auch jetzt eine Erinnerung, dass es einen Fix gab dafür, der in 10.6.2, glaube ich, drin ist.
Es gab so einen Performance-Fix-Dingsbums von... Nee, das war unabhängig, das kam einfach so raus. Und ich glaube, das galt nur für Nvidia-Chipsets. Nur die haben das gekriegt auch.
Ah, das liegt mit der Grafikkarte zusammen? Also für die neuen Systeme, auf denen das basiert ist, okay. Also mit anderen Worten, mich dürfte das auf meinem alten...
Dichte sollte es theoretisch gar nicht betroffen haben. Ich weiß aber nicht, ob das der Fall war oder nicht.
Gut.
Aber ich hatte zwischendurch auch mal den Verdacht, sterben die Festplatte, weil die Festplatte ja auch irgendwann noch mal relativ neu war und so was. Und die Festplatten sterben ja ganz gerne mal, wenn sie neu sind. Aber die Festplatte ist soweit total dufte. Und ich habe hier auch dieses Smart Tool, Smart Reporter und ich lasse regelmäßig meinen Check drüber laufen.
Das habe ich nämlich auch probiert. Also ich hatte einfach die Platte in Verdacht aus verschiedenen Gründen. Erstens ist es natürlich so, ist eine Platte langsam, dann ist es klar, dass das zur Verzögerung führt. Weil Dinge sind auf der Platte und öffnen von Dateien, Swap Space und der ganze Klim Bim, führt dazu. Und hab auch mal den Ranz gemacht und hab einfach mal, weil ich hatte nämlich dann auch auf dem iMac hier auch komische Verzögerungen. Und da dachte ich mir so, vielleicht liegt es ja doch mal wieder am Treiber. Der Mac hat ja nun nicht so ein ausgebufftes Treiber-Modell, dass der Körner gut isoliert wäre von dem, was die Treiber so tun. Kann abstürzen und so. Wir wissen alle, schlechte Treiber können eine Menge bringen. Dann hab ich mal so ein bisschen geguckt, wer denn hier eigentlich alles so Schindloder treibt und wer so irgendwie Prozessor-Zeit verbrät und das war alles ganz schön dramatisch. Also Drobo. Drobo-Treiber hab ich jetzt hier mal wieder deinstalliert, weil ich gesehen habe, dass da, also erstmal haben sie da so einen komischen Agenten laufen, irgendwie, wenn du diesen Treiber installierst, dann DD-Service-Demon, der dann auch noch irgendwie ordentlich CPU-Zeit gefressen hat, wo ich mich echt frage, was der macht. Aber es kam dann noch geiler, dann bin ich irgendwie auf Fehler-Suche in den Konsolen-Logs gegangen. Und alle 10 Sekunden war da ein Drobo-Eintrag, dachte ich mir so, oh holla, da haben sie irgendwie, da installieren sie sich auf diesen Rechnern und installieren einen 64-Bit-Service. Das ist aber ein ganz alter iMac, der kann auch gar keinen 64-Bit. Dann wird er halt immer wieder gestartet, stürzt natürlich ab, weil er keinen 64-Bit hat, es ist halt ein 64-Bit-Only-Binary. Sie haben einen DD-Service 64-D und einen DD-Service D.
Und der probiert beide zu starten?
Da dachte ich mir so, warum machen sie da keinen Fed-Binary? Das eine ist aber ein Fed-Binary, das ist PowerPC und Intel 32-Bit und dann haben sie noch mal einen für 64-Bit und dafür haben sie noch einen eigenen Service-Launch D31. Das ist vollkommen gaga.
Und der probierte dann alle?
Dann installieren sie halt diesen 64-Bit auf ein System, der das gar nicht kann. Das ist irgendwie auch ein bekanntes Problem, das habe ich mal kurz im Netz gesucht, sofort Antworten gefunden. Ich habe das einfach alles entfernt, weil ich brauche das eh nicht, weil dann nur die Platte darauf zugreifen. Das habe ich irgendwie dieses Dashboard nicht, aber darauf geschissen. Ich will eh mit diesem Drohnen nichts zu tun haben. Aber das hat das Problem auf dem iMac ein bisschen verbessert, auf meinem MacBook, aber irgendwie war einfach trotzdem noch Ende. Was war also jetzt das Problem? Dann habe ich Folgendes probiert. Ich habe einfach meinen MacBook mit Fire-Variant, meinen iMac angeschlossen, Target Disk Mode. Und dachte mir so, jetzt übertrage ich einfach mal den kompletten Inhalt auf eine andere Platte. Und dann boot ich mal davon und gucke, ob es immer noch so ist. Weil dann kann ich ja sagen, ob es irgendwie was mit der Platte zu tun hat oder nicht oder mit meinem Setup. Aber soweit kam es gar nicht, weil er hat irgendwie 8 Stunden gebraucht, um irgendwie ein Drittel dieser Festplatte irgendwie runterzulesen. Und da wusste ich schon, okay, hier ist irgendwie Kacke am Dampfen. Ich mache es jetzt mal ganz kurz. Ich habe mir eine neue Platte gekauft, habe die irgendwie extern angeschlossen. Habe jetzt auch eine extra Schnelle genommen, mal mit 7200 Umdrehungen, Scheiß auf den Lärm, das Ding ist eh zu laut. Und habe irgendwie alles rüberkopiert, dann die Platten ausgetauscht. Und als ich dann die interne Platte ans externe Gehäuse, wo ich vorher noch die Platte angeschlossen habe, eingeschleppt habe, kam es schon gar nicht mehr hoch.
Klack, fack, klack.
Letzte Sekunde und so. Weil, okay, ich hatte irgendwie teilweise Backups und so weiter. Aber manchmal hat man dann doch schon das Richtige gespürt. So, was dann aber noch ein Problem war, ich habe nicht einfach nur rüberkopiert, sondern ich habe ein frisches Snow-Leopard auch installiert. Und hatte danach irgendwie mit meinem neuen System aber irgendwie ein Problem. Alles hing auf einmal, Mail hing irgendwie, dachte ich so, was geht denn hier ab? Und was ich halt vergessen hatte, ist noch das Software-Update anzuschmeißen. Ich hatte also ein 10.6.0 mit Daten von einem 10.6.2. Und siehe da, das Adressbuch, wo es diverse Bugs gab, das alte Adressbuch, und zwar die Service-Einheit im Betriebssystem, die aus allen Programmen zur Verfügung steht, kam dann mit dieser Datenbank nicht klar. Und dadurch hingen halt irgendwie Mail und alle anderen Programme, die halt irgendwie dein Adressbuch scannen.
Aber war das nicht so, dass Snow Leopard sich jetzt irgendwie direkt bei der Installation noch Updates irgendwoher zieht? War das dann bei einem Drüberbügeln aus der alten Installation oder tatsächlich aus der Wolke?
Ich kenne das eigentlich auch so, dass er nach der Installation relativ frühzeitig schaut, aber irgendwie hat er das nicht getan. Keine Ahnung, vielleicht hatte ich in dem entscheidenden Moment irgendwie das Netz nicht dran. Tatsache war, das Update fehlte und nachdem ich halt auf 10.6.2 aktualisiert habe, war das dann irgendwie auch alles wieder gut. Aber bis dahin habe ich echt gekotzt, weil ich irgendwie nicht zu Ende gedacht hatte in dem Moment. Das ist ein generelles Problem, diese Rückwärtskompatibilität. Und wenn man halt irgendwie neue Systeme aufsetzt, sollte man tunigst darauf achten, auch gleich die richtige Version zu haben. Also ja, alles so ein Ding. Was auch noch beim 10.6.2 Update mit dabei war, ist ja ganz interessant, ist diese neue Keyboard-Firmware für die Wireless-Tastaturen. Da gab es ja vorher so einen Exploit, den jemand gezeigt hat, dass man da die Firmware reinwirft, die dann sozusagen auch nicht groß überprüft wird, ob die wirklich von Apple ist.
Das war nicht nur bei Wireless, das war auch bei USB-Tastaturen, ne?
Richtig, stimmt, genau, Entschuldigung. Das war generell für Tastaturen, nicht nur für Wireless.
Also ich hab nämlich keins in der Richtung bekommen, fällt mir gerade auf. Meine Tastatur ist theoretisch noch angreifbar.
Ja, ich weiß jetzt auch nicht ganz genau, auf welche Tastaturen das alles im Einzelnen ging, aber ich hab zumindest keine davon. Ich hab aber davon gelesen, dass sie das adressiert haben und jetzt haben sie da wohl auch noch irgendwie Signing eingeführt. Warum sie sowas nicht von vornherein machen? Ich meine, auch bei dem Software-Update war das ja am Anfang nicht so. Da muss ja auch erst mal einer aus der Security-Branche kommen und hier, ich kann dir irgendwie man-in-the-middle-mäßig Software-Updates unterschieben und so.
Ach, ist das mittlerweile tatsächlich geflixt? Ich dachte, das wäre immer noch ein Problem.
Doch, nee, meines Wissens ist das irgendwie seit 10, keine Ahnung, seit Ewigkeiten.
Ich finde, das Sparkle sollte eine HTTPS-Verbindung auf jeden Fall entforcen. Das würde ich mal für eine ganz tolle Sache halten, hier dieses...
Ja, also generell ist einfach so Vertrauen...
Wie viele auch sicherheitsrelevante Apps tatsächlich über eine normale HTTPS-Verbindung abgedatet werden, ist halt hart.
Vertrauen und Software-Updates, da ist definitiv noch was zu leisten.
Ein Zeichen.
Ich hab ein Zeichen gesehen.
Ich muss das machen mit dem Ton, oder? Warte, ich mach das nächstes Mal mit dem Ton. Ich mach das nächstes Mal, dass das Ding einfach so ein Ding-Dong macht und zwar ein Ding-Dong, was nur wir hören.
Ah, so ein Pavlovschluss.
Jabba. Jabba. Auf dem iPhone benutzt du?
Ja.
Mit ähm... Wie heißt das gleich?
B-Jive.
Genau, mit B-Jive.
Hast du das andere auch probiert?
Dieses, was gibt's denn noch? Ich hab jetzt überlegt, ob ich das andere nochmal probieren soll. Wie hieß denn das gleich?
E-M Plus.
E-M Plus hab ich probiert, ja. Das fand ich damals nicht so dufte. B-Jive find ich ganz super. Jetzt gibt's so ein neues. Wie heißt das so, was von Windows kommt? Trinity oder irgendwie sowas?
Ach so, Trillian.
Trillian gibt's jetzt fürs iPhone. Das iPhone sah auch auf den ersten Blick nicht so schlecht aus. Auch mit Push? Auch mit Push, auch mit einem Pipapo.
Interessant. Windows-Software kommt aufs iPhone. Jetzt hör mal, was Neues. Naja, ich hatte E-M Plus, die Lite-Version schon immer irgendwie mal installiert gehabt. Von diesen B-Jive gab's ja meines Wissens keine.
Ja, das B-Jive ist schon relativ teuer, muss man sagen.
Na, die nehmen sich da nichts. E-M Plus und B-Jive kosten beide 8 Euro. Und dann hab ich mir irgendwie einfach die E-M Plus-Version gekauft, aber bin dann aus verschiedenen Gründen nicht so richtig glücklich geworden. Dann hab ich halt mal dieses B-Jive ausprobiert und war total überrascht, wie cool diese Anwendung ist. Das ist gut, ne? Also das ist wirklich ein richtig guter Chat-Line. Aber was besonders gut dann funktionierte, ist, dass man bei B-Jive... War das jetzt eigentlich der Grund? Weiß ich nicht mehr ganz genau. Genau, ich wollte ja dann eine Co-Existenz haben mit meinem Jobber-Client auf dem Mac. Und wollte sozusagen auch ein definiertes Verhalten haben, wann ich denn nun meine Nachrichten aufs iPhone kriege und wann auf dem Mac. Und was ich haben wollte, ist, was ich jetzt auch habe, dass wenn ich online bin an meinem Mac und ich bin auch available, dann kriege ich sie da. Wenn ich gleichzeitig mit meinem iPhone online bin, dann kriege ich sie immer noch da. Wenn ich aber abwesend bin auf meinem Mac, dann möchte ich sie auf meinem iPhone haben. Wenn ich den da eingebucht bin natürlich. Das heißt, ich möchte in der Lage sein, mit einem jetzt bin ich auch wirklich an meinem Mac und nicht idle, möchte ich das iPhone overriden. Weil du hast natürlich bei diesem BeDrive-Kram nur die Möglichkeit zu sagen, wenn ich dir jetzt das Programm beende, dann bleib mal noch so und so viele Stunden online. Das kannst du dann mehr oder weniger filigran konfigurieren. Ich habe es glaube ich derzeit so auf 12 Stunden. So nach dem Motto, wenn ich 12 Stunden lang nicht Jabber auf dem iPhone benutzt habe, dann spielt es auch erstmal keine Rolle für mich. Im Prinzip könnte ich ja auch noch länger einstellen. Denn jetzt habe ich auch eine Lösung gefunden für das Problem. Das Problem ist nämlich, du musst, um so ein Verhalten zu erzeugen, deinem Jabber-Client sagen können, mit welcher Priorität er sich an deinem Jabber-Server anmeldet. Das ist eine Eigenschaft des Jabber-Protokolls, des XMPP-Protokolls. Und das ist ein Wert von 0 bis N. Also er kann theoretisch auch negativ sein, aber relevant sind eigentlich nur die Werte von 0 bis N. Und 0 ist sozusagen die niedrigste Priorität. Und umso höher die Priorität ist, mit der er angemeldet ist, umso größer die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass er auch die Nachrichten kriegt. Oder anders ausgedrückt, die Nachrichten gehen an den angemeldeten Client mit der höchsten Priorität. Jetzt bist du wahrscheinlich in deinem Adium.
Genau, jetzt bin ich gerade in meinem Adium.
Bei Adium kann man nämlich das konfigurieren. Bei Adium kann man das nämlich konfigurieren, welche Priorität er für available und für away hat. Und bei iChat kannst du weder noch einstellen. Ich habe dann ein bisschen geforscht, es gibt irgendwie eine P-List für iChat, wo tatsächlich eine Priority auftaucht, aber auch nur eine. Du bist online und dann hast du die Priorität sowieso. Ich habe die geändert mit allen P-List-Tools und so weiter, die mir zur Verfügung standen, aber es war diesem iChat zumindest eine aktuelle Version nicht beizubringen. Also mir ist es zumindest nicht gelungen. Ich habe von Leuten gehört, denen es über den Weg gelungen ist, aber es hat einfach nicht funktioniert. Ich konnte iChat es einfach nicht beibringen. Das war dann für mich der Zeitpunkt, wieder zurückzuwechseln auf Adium. Ich hatte das vor einiger Zeit mal verlassen, weil es mir einfach zu crashy war und ein paar Features fehlten, insbesondere diese horizontal Taps-Geschichte. Aber das habe ich jetzt festgestellt. Erstens crash das nicht mehr und zweitens haben sie auch da kräftig nachgearbeitet. Also Adium ist derzeit in einem...
Du meinst die Vertical-Taps oder was?
Nö, ich hätte sie gerne... Also ich habe gerne die Namen links. Achso, okay, die Taps, ja, das ist die Frage, von wo man jetzt guckt. Also ich habe die Namen links an meinem Fenster dran, übereinander und nicht dann sozusagen unten, weil das mehr Taps du hast, und mehr überlagert sich, das ist Quatsch. Und das ist eigentlich eine sehr schöne Sache, da kann man die Vorzüge von Audio mal wieder voll genießen. Und durch diese Umstellung kann ich also jetzt, bin ich viel besser erreichbar über Java. Und durch Twitter ist für mich ja Java auch wieder richtig nutzbar geworden, weil ich habe, also bei Java ist es so ein bisschen wie meine Geolocation, also ich nehme Leute von meinem Roster, mit denen ich nicht wirklich kommuniziere. Ein paar sind da noch drauf und so, ich will jetzt auch keine Leute verkrezen, aber für mich ist Java schon eher ein wichtiges Tool und ein richtiges Werkzeug. Das heißt, da habe ich die Leute, mit denen ich auch regelmäßig in Verbindung bin. Und von daher lohnt es sich für mich eben auch in zunehmendem Maße, immer erreichbar zu sein über Java mit dem iPhone dann, sodass ich jetzt wirklich Situationen hatte, schon mehrfach, wo ich halt dann auf dem iPhone in der Straßenbahn, im Zug oder was weiß ich Push-Nachrichten bekommen habe und es dann für mich auch eine Möglichkeit gab, zu responden.
Also B-Jav ist spätestens seitdem, also auf dem 3G war es immer ziemlich langsam. So bei B-Jav hat man jetzt so richtig den Fett, den Unterschied zwischen 3G und 3GS gemerkt. Das war richtig. Also 7-8 Sekunden auf dem iPhone, auf dem 3G gebraucht, auf dem 3GS ist das ja wirklich da. Also es ist nicht... Ja, beim Start. Könnte gerne noch ein bisschen schneller sein, aber schon mal wirklich eine dramatische Verbesserung. Und BeDrive, ja, sehr tolles Programm, nutze ich seit Ewigkeiten. Es hat auch so Sachen wie schaltet mich automatisch auf away, sobald ich das Programm beende und sowas, dass ich zu online bin, aber dass die Leute mitkriegen. Man kann auch eine Signatur einstellen.
Warum muss man das einstellen?
Ich glaube, das ist das Default-Verhalten auch. Man kann es aber relativ...
Mal ein bisschen testen.
Man kann es relativ fein granuiert einstellen, was man da gerne haben möchte. Diese Prioritäten habe ich da jetzt nicht gesehen. Bei mir ist es jetzt einfach so, das finde ich auch gar nicht so schlecht, dass es auf beiden Geräten die erste Nachricht kommt. Und sobald ich dann antworte, dann noch auf dem Gerät, auf dem ich geantwortet habe. Das finde ich, fand ich jetzt...
Es wird besser.
Fand ich okay.
Ja. Und da habe ich mich auch wieder daran erinnert, dass ich mir seinerzeit mal kein iPhone gekauft habe, weil ich der Meinung war, dass ich da ordentliches Jobber drauf haben will. Und das ging ja irgendwie alles nicht mit keine Applikationen bzw. kein iJet-Serien-mäßig oder dann halt die App Store-Problematik und Background-Prozess-Problematik und war eigentlich nie ein Freund von diesem Push-Kram mit irgendwie Diensten, die mir mein Passwort irgendwie abspeichern.
Stimmt.
Bin ich auch immer noch kein Freund von.
Ja, aber es ist doch sehr komfortabel.
Ja, es ist so scheiße.
Oh man, man ist so inkonsequent. Also von daher, also als sicherheitsrelevante Account sollte man definitiv nicht über so einen Dienst machen. Das kann man einfach mal dazu sagen. Und ich hoffe, dass er sich da auch noch mal eine andere Lösung findet. Zumindest müsste es die Möglichkeit geben, ich weiß gar nicht, ob Jabba da irgendwie eine Möglichkeit hat, mit Credentials zu arbeiten. So wie mit Open, nicht OpenID, sag ich schon.
Also dass man quasi die Applikation, das Recht gibt, auf deine Accounts zu kaufen.
Genau, wie man das jetzt im Webbenzunehmenden Maße auch macht, mit Twitter und so weiter. Wie heißt denn das Protokoll noch? OAUS, genau. Also dass man sowas macht, dass ich quasi dem BeDrive-Server sage, okay, der darf sich jetzt für mich anmelden, weil der hat jetzt irgendwie gerade mein Vertrauen und das Vertrauen expired am Um. Aber er erkennt mein Passwort nicht.
Ich hab da mal neuerlich mit diesem OAUS, da war im Endeffekt mein Fehler, aber war mein Account plötzlich gesperrt, geblockt bei Twitter für eine Stunde, weil ich zu oft das Passwort falsch eingegeben habe. Da hab ich so gedacht, oh, war vielleicht mal eine Blödheit. Hatte noch eine Session offen, die noch funktionierte und hab da erstmal richtig schön aussortiert, was ich da alles hinten reingerammelt hatte in den Applikationen, denen ich irgendwann mal zugelassen habe und natürlich nie wieder rausgeschmissen habe, wie sich das gehört.
Oh, gibt's da eine Liste?
Da gibt's eine Liste. Da gibt's unter Account-Einstellung. Bei Twitter gibt's nur, wenn du welche hast, natürlich. Ja klar, du musst ja auch das Recht wieder entziehen können, ansonsten ist das ja total armer.
Ja, aber ich hab ehrlich gesagt die Stelle noch nie gefunden in Settings.
Settings, Connections, ganz hinten.
Und da stehen die alle schön aufgelistet. Und da kannst du rein und raus.
Wer ist denn da, alles dabei?
Sieh mal an!
Da schmeiß ich ja gleich mal wieder ein paar raus hier.
Alles, was ich nicht weiß, was es ist, ist erstmal schon mal draußen.
Wo waren wir gerade stehen geblieben?
Immer noch bei Jabba.
Also alles ist gut und ich kann das empfehlen und ich weiß, es ist teuer, aber es lohnt sich. Also wer für den Jabba wichtig ist, den sollte diese 8 Euro nicht viel ausmachen. Ich kann das irgendwie empfehlen. Ob Trillian was taugt, werden wir sehen.
Quick Time!
Haben wir auch schon mal ausführlich besprochen. Mir ist fast aufgefallen. Und zwar erstens, wie wenig das Ding kann. Und einer Hinsicht, wenn du jetzt irgendwie Kameras anschließt, kannst du ja nicht irgendwie und nicht auswählen, mit welcher Kamera du arbeiten willst oder so, wenn du eine Videoaufzeichnung machst. Oder kriegt man dann eine Auswahl?
Ich hab's nie probiert.
Also es ist irgendwie, mir fehlt da nach wie vor so ein bisschen dieser QuickTime 7-Komfort. Das ist irgendwie so ein bisschen anstrengend. Aber wenn man jetzt irgendwie New Movie Recording macht und man hat irgendwie mehrere Kameras angeschlossen, dann fragt er nicht, welcher man gerne aufzeichnen möchte.
Das ist ja mal hart.
Oder hat man dann doch dieses, ach nee, doch es gibt dann dieses Pop-Up. Ah nee, Entschuldigung, ich behaupte das Gegenteil.
Das Blödsinn.
Was meinte ich denn da jetzt? Ich hatte irgendwie nur das Problem, das, was ist denn das für ein Problem? Ach ja, das Problem mit so HD-Kameras, wie man denen irgendwie dann auch das HD entlockt und so weiter. Okay, vergiss das, was ich über QuickTime gesagt habe. Also ich wollte erstmal auf was anderes raus, in Bezug auf QuickTime X. Mir ist nämlich aufgefallen, als ich neulich Movies encoded habe, dass QuickTime X offensichtlich, das ist jetzt eine reine Vermutung von mir, aber offensichtlich in der Lage ist MPEG 4 H264 Advanced Profiles oder heißt es Main Profiles abzuspielen. Also es gibt ja da diese MPEG 4, der Standard die große Wolke, H264, die zweite Iteration des Video Codecs, der sozusagen der Hippe ist. Aber H264 ist selber ja auch eigentlich nichts anderes als ein riesen Framework von Codec Features, die dann wiederum gruppiert sind in sogenannte Profiles. Das heißt ein Profile, das du selektierst, sagt, welche Features werden da unterstützt. Und was bisher auf dem iPod immer angesagt war, als der iPod 5G rauskam, konnte der im Wesentlichen Baseline-Profile. Baseline-Profile macht halt nicht so viel advancedes Zeug. Das heißt, du kannst nicht so super mega gut im Coden, wie du vielleicht möchtest. Aber du hältst natürlich auch die Anforderungen auf der Decoder-Seite niedrig. Was für so CPU-Anforderungen und Anforderungen an die Hardware, die unter Umständen das macht, beim iPod halt dieser Chip, das entsprechend niedrig hält. Außerdem ist das Baseline-Profile definiert frei von weiterführenden Lizenzen. Lizenzzahlungen, wenn du da Kodex für machst. So und QuickTime 7 konnte meiner Erkenntnis nach auch nicht sehr viel mehr. Wenn du also die MPEG-4 H264-Material angeschaut hast, was jetzt so typischerweise auf Pirate Bay rumgeht, dann ist das halt häufig Main-Profile gewesen. So dass du da auch schon so die advancederen Fähigkeiten drin hattest. Mit dem Ergebnis, dass obwohl ja nun der MPEG-4 aware ist und sehr wohl H264 kann, eben nicht diese Profiles unterstützt hat. Diese Videos öffneten jetzt mit Snow Lappert. Meine Vermutung ist also, QuickTime X kann Man-Profile, was man eigentlich auch erwarten möchte. Gerade von einem Proponenten von MPEG-4 wie Apple. Das war schon immer ein Problem. Aber das scheint sich jetzt erst mit QuickTime X zu machen. Du hast wirklich den Effekt, du sitzt an einem Rechner und du kannst halt mit dem QuickTime X-Player was angucken, was du mit dem QuickTime 7-Player nicht angucken kannst. Was man ja nicht erwarten möchte, aber so ist das.
Also jetzt hat man den Fall, dass einige Sachen da gehen und andere Sachen da gehen.
Genau, mehr Features bei QuickTime 7, mehr Fähigkeiten und vor allem mehr Performance bei QuickTime X. Man merkt richtig, das ist Migration.
Ich hab neulich das erste Mal ein Interview auf dem iPhone geführt, also ein Video-Interview. Und hab mit dem Totalversagen gerechnet. Also ich war auf dem SPD-Parteitag und laute Umgebung und hab einfach das iPhone rausgeholt und draufgehalten und dachte, da wird man nachher kein Wort verstehen können. Das Mikro wird total scheiße sein. Es ging, es ging erstaunlich gut. Man kann es, ohne dass ich den Ton nachbearbeiten musste, so halbwegs verstehen. Das ist natürlich so, wenn man das iPhone selber in der Hand hält, wenn man selber spricht, ist man perfekt zu verstehen. Die Person, die vor einem steht, die hört man nur mittelgut. Die Video-Qualität ist überraschend gut. Und dieses Schneiden mit QuickTimeX, da mal eben so dieses Ding hin und her schieben, das geht zwar nicht so schön mit Cursor-Taste und Haar genau und sowas, aber wenn man so sagt, ich schneide hier mal so grob und ich will es schnell weghaben, dann trimmst du das, klickst auf den lade die Scheiße auf YouTube-Hoch-Button, dann wird das entkodiert, das geht auch ratzfatz. Also es ging echt schnell. Und dann wurde das ganze Zeug hochgeladen. Das hängt dann natürlich immer davon ab, wie schnell das Internet gerade ist, aber ich war sehr angetan von diesem ganzen Prozess, wie lange das dauerte, also früher kannte ich das noch so, wenn man auf YouTube Videos hochgeladen hat, dann konnte man ungefähr vier Stunden warten, bis das Video dann tatsächlich erschienen ist, bis es irgendwann mal in einer Reihe dran war. Ich nehme an, dass Apple das von vornherein im Format hochlädt, das YouTube mag, nämlich MPEG4.
Ja klar. Das muss nicht mehr umgerechnet werden.
Dass da nichts mehr umgerechnet werden muss, es ist sofort da, es ist wohl, aber sie schreiben dazu, dass sie ihre Prozesse verbessert haben müssen. Das Video ist noch nicht ganz fertig. Die Qualität kann sich im Laufe der Zeit noch verbessern. Ich nehme an, dass sie da irgendwas noch zurecht optimieren. Oder ist die vielleicht erst mal nur eine kurze FLV-Version? Ich weiß nicht was.
Rechnen sie doch um und machen erst mal die Schlechteste erst, weil die schneller geht.
Genau. Wenn man noch ein anderes Mikro an das iPhone anschließen könnte, dann wäre das eine okaye Interview-Plattform. Oder Berichterstattungsplattform, womit ich so beim besten Willen nie gerechnet hätte.
Ja, wenn man noch Livestreaming hätte, ne?
Wenn das mal ginge, ha ha ha, in einer Fernzukunft.
Und der Martin hier auch gerade auf Twitter beklagt, kurz vor der Sendung.
Da hat er recht.
Ich meine, diese HTTP-Streaming, was sie jetzt als Kleinfeature eingebaut haben, das können sie auch gerne als Serverfeature machen, dass man das auch als Upload benutzen kann.
Stimmt eigentlich. Das unterstützen jetzt ja so ziemlich alle, ne? Silverlight unterstützt was mittlerweile.
Ich verweise auf den letzten Chaos Radio Express, der veröffentlicht wurde, zum Thema Streaming. Da haben wir uns zwar das Detail Silverlight ausgeklammert. Aber ich kann dir jetzt zumindest einen Überblick geben. Der Überblick ist der, HTTP wird jetzt schon von den meisten verwendet, sowohl bei Microsoft als auch bei Apple als auch bei Adobe. Aber die sind sich da noch nicht ganz grün. Also bei Microsoft ist es mal wieder irgendwie die andere Codec. Das heißt, das Ganze geht nur mit WMV. Und bei Adobe weiß man gerade noch nicht so ganz genau, was da jetzt kommt. Könnte mir durchaus vorstellen, dass die auch auf die Apple-Linie da einscheren. Apple wiederum hat im Prinzip nichts anderes gemacht, als Shoutcast, MP3, HTTP-Streaming zu nehmen und weiterzuentwickeln. Insofern als dass sie eben dasselbe Playlist-Format verwenden oder auf Basis einer PLS-Datei indizieren, was es sozusagen gibt. Und an sich ist das alles eine schöne Sache, weil man halt mit dem HTTP-Streaming wunderbar seinen bereits aufgenommenen Content quasi auf der Platte schon in Schnipsel zerteilen kann. Da gibt es irgendwie so Skripte, die man finden kann. Und dann hast du quasi Live-Streaming für Prerecorded Content, den du mit dem HTTP-Server ausliefern kannst. Also du brauchst keinen Streaming-Server. Du hörst es einfach auf deinen Web-Server. Aber für Live willst du natürlich etwas haben, was direkt das macht. Auf dem Mac gibt es da Tools wie zum Beispiel Wirecast, was vom User-Interface her ein bisschen gewinnungsbedürftig ist, vom Preis her nicht unerheblich. 500 Euro. Aber die haben wir so in der neuesten Version auch die Möglichkeit, HTTP-Streaming direkt zu machen. Allerdings interessant ist natürlich, wie du das redest, zu bedurten kannst, weil du willst natürlich nicht von deinem Rechner aus alle deine Clients bedienen, es sind sehr wenig. Deswegen ist es ja viel interessanter, zu Ustream und so weiter, livestream.com und so weiter hochzuladen. Das kannst du halt derzeit über RTP, RTSP machen, da kannst du also auch den normalen QuickTime-Broadcaster verwenden. Und die machen dann halt HTTP-Streaming fürs iPhone in zunehmendem Maße. Ich weiß nicht, bei wem es jetzt schon überall offiziell ein vollwertiger Dienst ist, aber it's coming up. Das tun sie jetzt halt einfach, weil es ja nur ein anderes Outlet ist. Nur auf dem iPhone gibt es halt wieder ein also weder gibt es halt für Audio eine Streaming-Applikation, was ja durchaus vorstellbar war, dass jemand mal sowas rausbringt. Sowas wie NiceCast sozusagen, aber Roka Möber steht da glaube ich nicht für zur Verfügung. Das werden wir eh gleich nochmal besprechen. Video geht schon gar nicht, weil das geht auch schon glaube ich von der iPhone-App her gar nicht, dass du den Videostream live kriegst. Du kannst halt nur sagen, nimm mir mal ein Video auf und gibs mir dann.
Ja, ja genau.
Also ich rechne damit, dass das kommt, aber derzeit gibt es das halt irgendwie alles noch gar nicht.
Den Teil finde ich übrigens auch bei Quick relativ hübsch gelöst. Ich habe neulich mal bei einem Konzert ein, zwei Songs gestreamt mit Quick. Das fühlt sich auch so ein bisschen future-mäßig an. Also man nimmt das auf halt.
QIK auf ein gejailbreaktes iPhone dann oder was?
Auf ein gejailbreaktes kriegst du das live, wenn du magst. Das habe ich jetzt aber nicht gemacht, sondern ich habe einfach die aus dem App Store genommen.
Achso, der nimmt auf und danach wirft er das hoch?
Genau, was ja auch...
Wo ist der Unterschied zu YouTube?
Dass du noch direkt einen Twitter-Button hast und dann dich auch nicht darum kümmern brauchst. Du hast einfach eine Kurzbeschreibung angeht, einen Twitter-Button klickst und so.
Das ist schon gelöst. Mehr ist es nicht.
Stimmt, das könnte man eigentlich auch per YouTube machen. Bin ich noch nicht mal drauf gekommen.
So, was haben wir noch?
Ja, das musst du jetzt erzählen. Da habe ich gerade, als ich das gelesen habe, erst mal von dir gehört.
Ja, ich habe es mal aufgeschrieben, weil ich dachte, ich komme noch ein bisschen mehr zum Testen, als es mir letztendlich gelungen ist. Aber man muss es auf jeden Fall mal erwähnen, weil es ein interessanter, frischer Ansatz ist. Erfahrungen, wie gesagt, sind sehr eingeschränkt. Ich habe es jetzt gerade mal irgendwie installiert bekommen und ein bisschen versucht, ein paar Pakete damit zu übersetzen, was soweit auch erst mal gelungen ist. Worum handelt es sich? Es handelt sich um einen Paketmanager, so wie MacPorts und so wie Fink sind. Während Fink allerdings aus der Linux-Ecke kommt.
Das hat so ein bisschen Abt-Get drin, aber nicht so richtig.
Genau, aber es basiert sozusagen da drauf.
Es gibt da auch zwei. Es gibt die Source-Variante und die Abt-Get-Variante.
Bei Fink.
Die sind, glaube ich, technisch ein bisschen unterschiedlich.
Das eine holt er den Source und übersetzt das, das andere installiert Binaarpakete. Aber ich habe mit Fink extrem lange keine Erfahrung mehr gemacht. Das will ich mich da gar nicht zu äußern. Mehr Erfahrungen, weil ich das auch regelmäßig benutze, sind halt mit Mac-Ports. Das kommt eben aus der FreeBSD-Ecke. Und von den Leuten gehackt worden, die vorher die FreeBSD-Ports gemacht haben. Und haben im Vergleich zu den FreeBSD-Ports da viele Verbesserungen eingebaut, was die Benutzung macht, mit mehrere Versionen gleichzeitig installiert haben. Und dann aktiviert man die, die man gerade braucht und solche Geschichten. Allerdings haben die alle das gleiche Problem, dass eben da nun mal Mac OS nicht so als Open Source Unix-Distribution daherkommt und selber keinen Paketmanager-Dienst mitbringt, man sich da eben auch nirgendswo einklinken kann. Mit dem Ergebnis, dass wenn du Mac-Ports runterlädst, dass du eben alles...
Über Ports installieren musst.
Alles nachinstallieren musst. Das heißt, installierst du etwas, was Pearl braucht, dann lädt er sich erstmal Pearl runter und installiert Pearl.
Und das ist ein richtig großes Problem, wenn man. Also es gibt CouchDB als native Mac OS 10 App, die hat dann so einen Icon im Dock, das wollte ich aber eigentlich nach Möglichkeit nicht sagen, ich wollte so richtig die Demon im Hintergrund laufen haben.
Ich nehme doch die desktop-Applikation. Das heißt, man brüht sich sozusagen seine Ports zusammen. Aber es basiert auf Git und kann sich, also jetzt bewege ich mich auf sehr dünnen Eis, weil ich habe mir jetzt, das so ein bisschen, versteht das mal mehr als Hinweis darauf, dass es das gibt und sammelt eure eigenen Erfahrungen. Ich muss jetzt auch gerade nochmal meine, bevor ich hier dummes Zeug erzähle.
Achso, ich dachte, wir wären schon dabei.
Ich hole ich diesen Folder bei, du dummes Zeug zu erzählen. Ich muss nochmal kurz diese Keypoints von Homebroom mir hier vor die Nase holen, um da eine Aussage zu machen. Also erst mal kannst du wunderbar das irgendwie in deinem Home-Direktorie installieren. Und es ist komplett self-contained. Also Mac-Ports hat ja diese Eigenschaft, leider, dass ein paar Ports auch außerhalb des Bereiches was installieren. Dann hast du auf einmal was in Slash-Applications und dann installiert du dir mal was in Slash-Library und so. Naja, das ist so eine Sache. Außerdem installieren sie halt dann auch alles, was du installierst. Wenn du ein Paket installierst, dann landet das dann in einem Direktorie. Und sie machen alles andere mit Swim-Links. Das heißt, um diese typische Unix-Struktur danach hinzubekommen, damit es auch läuft, das machen sie alles mit Swim-Links. Aber der eigentliche Scheiß ist dann in einem Direktorie. Das heißt, du kannst zur Not deine Ports auch mit RM bewegen. Das ist an sich ein sehr schöner Aspekt und sollte auch die Angst vor dem Tool senken.
Ich glaube, das könnte auch ganz praktisch sein, wenn man ein System-Update macht oder einen Clean-Install und wenn man dann so eine komplette Infrastruktur mitnehmen möchte.
Ja, das geht bei Mac-Ports mit Einschränkungen auch. Also meine Slash-Opt-Nummer nehme ich normalerweise mit. Aber ich weiß, welche Ports das machen.
Ich habe es bisher noch nie gemacht, weil ich wahrscheinlich auch wegen Fink folge.
Das ist etwas, wo sie eben auch sagen, da achten wir darauf, dann auch so kleine Details sind nett. Das heißt, du benutzt dieses Brutool und wenn es Sudo braucht, dann fragt es dich irgendwie nach deinem Passwort. Nicht irgendwie, du machst das erstmal und dann schlägt es fehlen. Dann probierst du es mit Sudo und dann geht es. So ist Mac-Ports leider darauf, dass du da irgendwie entweder zu viel oder zu wenig Sudo benutzt, aber nicht so viel, wie es irgendwie nötig wäre. Und man kann auch sehr leicht Packages erzeugen. Also du kannst irgendwie ihn direkt auf ein Tabloid zeigen und dann baut er dir irgendwie da selber sein Package zusammen. Wie gut das funktioniert, das weiß ich nicht, aber offensichtlich machen sie das zumindest sehr einfach, weil Portfiles erzeugen ist ein großes Problem. Bei Mac-Ports sind viele Sachen auch nicht drin. Also man kann da nicht Sudo aus dem Vollen schöpfen, wie man gerne möchte. Ich weiß jetzt noch nicht, wie es bei Homebrew aussieht, aber zumindest ist es schon mal so ausgelegt, dass es eben die Sache etwas einfacher macht. Sie sagen, dass sie eben alles auf deinen Mac hin optimiert compilen. Das heißt, wenn du ein Port übersetzt, dann wählen sie nicht nur die richtige Rechner-Architektur aus, sondern sie versehen den Übersetzungsprozess. Also auch hier habe ich keine praktischen Erfahrungen. Das ist ihre Aussage. Du hast eine 64-Bit-Maschine, dann ist es irgendwie natürlich 64-Bit. Aber sie machen auch die ganzen Compiler-Flex, die jetzt für diesen spezifischen Prozessor, also dein Mac-Model sozusagen, alles das rausholt. Also sie compilen nichts rein, mit dem dein Mac nichts anfangen kann, beziehungsweise was unter Umständen das Executable langsamer macht, als es sein müsste. Darum geht es halt, dass es einfach schnell ist. Sie sagen, wie sagen sie so schön? Slow Software Sucks. Und da haben sie auch echt recht. Ja, dann gibt es irgendwie... Ah ja, genau. Und der Punkt, also soweit fand ich das alles ganz interessant, aber wo ich richtig aufgehört habe, aufgehäucht habe, ist, dass sie einerseits nicht dir halt nochmal einen Python runterladen, obwohl du ja schon eins hast, irgendwas, was auf Python basiert zu installieren. Sondern sie wollen explizit alles das, was da ist, ZLib, OpenSSL, tralala und so weiter, einfach out of the box mitverwenden. Das heißt, sie versprechen, ob sie das halten können, weiß ich nicht, sie versprechen oder sie möchten gerne in diese Richtung gehen, dass du eben nur ein Paket installierst, dass du möglichst alles, das was sowieso schon da ist, einfach benutzen. So, dazu müssen sie natürlich diverse Linking und Flag-Magic machen, damit dann eben auch diese Pakete gefunden werden, aber offensichtlich sind sie jetzt nicht zu faul, das OS da so weit zu re-ingenieren und zu verstehen, um einfach die entsprechenden Pfade zu präsentieren, damit eben diese Pakete auch gefunden werden von diesen ganzen Configure-Skripts und so, was dann irgendwie alles anläuft. Naja, du kannst dann irgendwie auch Packages dann halt mit Git forken. Da wird es halt wirklich interessant, dass sie quasi dieses offene Modell von Distributed Version Control auch auf Ports hin erheben. Das heißt, du hängst nicht mehr so sehr ab von einem DAS Portfile Repository. Du kannst natürlich auch bei Mac-Ports dir irgendwelche Portfiles runterladen und die installieren. Das geht natürlich auch. Aber dann sind sie auch komplett raus aus diesem ganzen Versions-Control-Dings. Und hier wird halt irgendwie auf Basis von Git und GitHub da gearbeitet. Und sie können auch gleich irgendwie über Git-URLs, über Subversion-URLs, über CVS-URLs oder Mercurial-URLs dir Sachen runterladen. Das heißt, du kannst halt irgendwie einen Package-Manager benutzen, um Sachen direkt aus einem Git-Repository heraus zu installieren. Das ist schon scharf. Das ist schon das, was man eigentlich so haben will.
Klingt so, als ob mein Portikus jetzt nicht seit Tagen rumkompiliert hätte. Obwohl, das sollte ja eigentlich kein Problem sein.
Da ist sozusagen, man sollte jetzt schon, also Mac-Ports kann man ja schon so ein bisschen Leuten auch zutrauen, die nicht mal, was weiß ich, wenn jemand MP4-Chaps haben will, dann installiere ich hier mal Mac-Ports und sage mal...
Kennst du Portikus?
Den Satz noch zu Ende. Bei Humbo würde ich das derzeit nicht tun. Portikus?
Portikus ist ein GUI für Mac-Ports.
Ach, gibts mal wieder eins. Mit K oder mit C?
Mit C.
Portikus.
Und ich benutze das. Fürs meiste, weil es zeigt mir einfach... Also ich meine so... Ich weiß, dass ich es auch auf der Shell verwenden kann, aber um jetzt mal so...
Seit wann gibt es das denn?
Requires Mac OS 10.4.
Das scheint es schon lange zu geben.
Aber wird das noch gepflegt?
Ist das up to date? Ich weiß jetzt nicht, wann das letzte Mal eine Version rauskam, aber ich habe jetzt keine Probleme mit der. Die läuft jetzt mit der aktuellen Version von Mac Ports und ich bin damit eigentlich ziemlich glücklich. Und es ist ja wirklich ein reines User Interface. Also wenn irgendwas nicht geht, kann man es immer nur über die Shell machen.
Ja, es gab ja ganz zu Anfang bei Mac Ports schon mal ein User Interface. Das ist dann aber schnell fallen gelassen worden, aus Gründen, die ich nicht ganz verstanden habe.
Kann durchaus sein, dass das Portikus war und dass sie das irgendwie wieder aus der Versenkung hervorgehoben haben.
Ich weiß gar nicht mehr, wie hieß denn das Ding eigentlich. Ich glaube, das hieß einfach da, da war es noch Darwin Ports. Ach so. Aber irgendwie wollten sie es nicht... Ich weiß nicht genau, was der Grund war. Vielleicht ist einfach der Programmierer verstorben oder die hat keinen Bock drauf oder jemand ist so kompliziert oder Bodennebel.
Also jetzt zeigt auf jeden Fall, sieht man die Option relativ hübsch und so was.
Porticus. Kann man mitarbeiten. Homebrew müssen wir mal testen. Du hast jetzt noch was hier.
Genau.
Ah, du hast das ausprobiert mit Better Touch Tool. Davon habe ich schon gehört.
Genau. Also angefangen habe ich jetzt mit einem Multi-Clutch heißt das. Wer es richtig aussprechen kann, soll es richtig aussprechen. Das ist für die Touchbats, die man so im MacBook und MacBook Pro hat, in den aktuellen Modellen, kann man damit ein paar mehr Tastaturbelegungen machen. Also dass man zum Beispiel per Finger wischen mit drei Fingern, dass man auch in Programmen, die es nicht unterstützen, Aktionen auslösen kann. Weil ich habe mich so unglaublich daran gewöhnt, dass ich in Firefox-Taps mit drei Fingern nach unten bzw. nach oben wischen kann. Finde ich echt, wollte ich das auch in anderen Programmen haben. Das geht jetzt mit Multi-Clutch so halb. Was sind das Programme? Multi-Clutch ist ein System-Preference-Tool. Und da kann man dann auswählen, welche Programme. Was ist das so?
Multi-Clutch?
C-L-U-T-C-L-A.
Ich hab jetzt gerade noch mal geguckt, das heißt so viel wie Foto oder Multi?
Ach so, mehrfach Foto. Mehrpfötige Benutzung des Eingabegerätes.
Das User-Interface ist gewöhnungsbedürftig, um es freundlich auszudrücken. Und es funktioniert nicht in allen Apps. Aus irgendeinem Grund geht es dann plötzlich in WebKit oder Safari nicht. Da kann ich einfach keine Tastenbelegung neu definieren. Das scheint etwas besser zu gehen mit BetterTouchTool. Damit habe ich jetzt mal ganz kurz ausprobiert. Das geht auch mit der Magic Mouse. Man hat hier noch ein paar Mehr-Einstellungen, die man machen kann.
Was ist jetzt auch eine Magic Mouse?
Ich habe keine, aber ich nutze es jetzt mit dem Trackpad. Die aktuelle Version geht auch mit der Magic Mouse.
Es geht aber nur mit den neueren, mit den Glass-Trackpads.
Es geht nur mit den Glass-Trackpads, bzw.
Also schon auch noch eine Generation vor dem Glass, aber schon so die ersten, die als Multitouch-Trackpads auch wirklich beworben wurden. Weil Zweifinger habe ich ja hier auch auf meinem MacBook.
Stimmt, Zweifinger hast du auch. Keine Ahnung, was man damit noch so machen kann. Kannst du ja mal ausprobieren einfach.
Die Empfehlung war jetzt nicht Multiklatsch, sondern das andere.
Genau, dieses Better Touch Tool. Also sie haben hier Vorfinger, 11-Finger-Tab. Tip-Tap, was auch immer ein Tip-Tap ist.
Tip-Tap Left, Tip-Tap Right.
Ach so, das ist dann wahrscheinlich so Klack, Klack, Klack. Also dass man einen Finger liegen lässt mit dem anderen titscht. Das ist zum Beispiel auch eine ganz hübsche Geste, die so gar nicht genutzt wird, glaube ich. Ja, auf jeden Fall kann man damit viel machen. Also ein bisschen so, ich hab mir einen Text-Mate-Tab-Wechsel per drei Finger-Bewegung und sowas, das ist echt geil.
Dit will man haben.
Multibettenschirm, ich bin echt ein bisschen hirnbeschränkt hier. Ich bekomme gerade über Twitter mit, dass wir auch gerade in Indien gehört werden. In Indien? Ja, Grüße nach Indien.
Ich kenne jemand in Indien. Ich kenne jemand, der gerade in Indien ist. Das hätte theoretisch die sein können, darum frage ich.
Gut, von Indern.
Alles klar. Ja, Better Touch Tool. Mehr wollte ich gar nicht zu dem Thema sagen. Wollen wir zum eigentlich spannenden Teil kommen?
Better Touch Tool.
Ich wollte es gerade mal ausprobieren, aber ich mach das nachher. Das lenkt mich alles nur total ab hier.
Das geht nicht, wenn man zu zweit ist.
Das lenkt einen total ab. Die Sache, jetzt kommen wir wieder in diesen App Store Kram. Und ich wollte auch mal jemanden dazu holen, damit wir nicht ganz alleine rum sitzen.
Mir fällt gerade an, der App Store Review Prozess ist wahrscheinlich die Hölle für Software. Das ist so, wenn Firefox abends Google Chrome schlafen legt, dann sagt das, und wenn du morgen nicht aufist, dann kommst du in den App Store Review Prozess.
Jetzt bin ich gespannt, wie ein Flitzebogen, ob das jetzt hier akustitechnisch funktioniert. Deswegen mache ich das jetzt hier auch nochmal ein Thema, bevor wir das eigentlich haben wollen. Und ich rufe mal Dirk an. Jetzt haben wir wahrscheinlich gleich Skype-spezifische Töne.
Willkommen bei Mobile.
Tim probiert sein neues Equipment aus.
Das ist alles sehr spannend. Jetzt höre ich schon mal nichts, das ist schon mal nicht gut.
Wieso höre ich nichts?
Ah, warte mal, irgendwas ist A. Keine Panik, keine Panik, keine Panik, keine Panik. Ich habe alles unter Kontrolle. So, da hören wir jetzt auch schon eine Stimme. Dirk?
Hallo Tim.
Hallo, guten Tag.
Hallo Dirk.
Du bist, wie man so schön sagt, on Air. Kannst du uns hören oder nicht? Ah, er kann uns nicht hören. Hallo?
Mist.
Ja, genau. Außerdem habe ich ihn irgendwie in meinem rechten Ohr. Das ist irgendwie auch sehr verdächtig.
Ich habe ihn auch in meinem rechten Ohr.
Also, jetzt sage ich ihm jetzt erstmal, dass wir ihn hören.
Okay, ich höre euch leider nicht. Ich frage mich gerade, woran das liegen kann.
Sag also nichts, was man gegen dich erwenden könnte. Nein, das ist definitiv mein Problem.
Ja, so ist das live, meine Damen und Herren.
So ist das.
Da spielen die Technik mal wieder nicht mit.
So, ich stelle nochmal hier um.
Jetzt klingst du auf jeden Fall schon mal besser.
Das kann ich euch immer noch nicht hören.
Aber er klingt doch einfach sehr schlecht.
Nee, das Problem liegt definitiv auf meiner Seite. Das schreibe ich ihm auch nochmal kurz. Problem ist auch...
Vielleicht können wir das nochmal versuchen, die Verbindung aufzubauen?
Nee, die Verbindung ist nicht das Problem.
Oh, okay, verstehe.
So, warum eigentlich?
Ja, ich habe euch bis gerade zugehört, aber jetzt ist die Unterhaltung genau andersrum einseitig.
Wie, jetzt hörst du uns oder wie?
Schade, dass es direkt beim ersten Mal nicht so richtig funktioniert.
Egal, sag erstmal nichts. Ich nehme jetzt erstmal raus. Ich muss jetzt erstmal gucken, dass ich irgendwie... Du kannst ja schon mal irgendwie... Berichte du doch mal von Rook Amilba, was du weißt. Du weißt auch alles darüber, oder?
Ja, ich weiss darüber. Die haben ja, die Tim ja auch gerade sehr schätzt, für ihre diversen Audio-Applikationen. Die haben eine Audio-Applikation, in der man Sound von beliebigen Programmen auf das iPhone streamen kann. Und die haben irgendwann vor Ureven-Zeiten eine Version 1.0 rausgebracht. Und das war dann, das war soweit kein Problem. Da war ein paar Bugs drin und haben sie ein paar Tage später eine Version 1.0.1 hinterhergeschoben. Und dachte, naja, wird die wahrscheinlich in zwei, drei Wochen da sein, mitnichten. Es hat über drei Monate gedauert, bis sie diese Version durch hatte. Und zwar wegen bizarrester Copyright- Infringement-Claims seitens Apple. Und zwar hat dieses Tool, wie heißt das eigentlich? Den Namen weiß ich jetzt nicht.
Airfoil-Speaker oder Touch-Speaker, Airfoil Touch. Das ist dieses Airfoil, das funktioniert wie Airtunes, aber nicht Airtunes ist. Zwar mit Airtunes arbeiten.
Es funktioniert auch mit Airtunes Boxen.
Es kann an Airtunes samplen.
Aber es kann nicht so tun, als sei es Airtunes. Also du kannst auf die Airfoil-Speaker nur mit Airfoil schicken, während Airfoil auch auf die Airtunes-Speaker schicken kann.
Genau. Und was die da mit schicken mit diesem ganzen Ding, ist ein kleines Bild erstens von dem Computer, den man so hat. Weil, wie ihr das wahrscheinlich wisst, unter Computer sieht man ja sein eigenes MacBook oder eben was man da gerade so fröhlich rumfliegen hat. Man sieht einen Screenshot von dem aktuellen Bildschirm enthalten und man sieht ein kleines Icon des Programms. Zum Beispiel Safari oder wie auch immer. Was man sich gerade übertragen lässt, ist ja ein schöner Informationsgehalt. Nun hat Apple sich aber wirklich auf die Hinterbeine gestellt und hat einfach über drei Monate gesagt, dass das überhaupt nicht angehen darf, dass das ja das massive Copyright-Problem sei, wenn dieses Programm einfach so, dass Safari Icon aufs iPhone überträgt, beziehungsweise das Icon von dem Mac. Was natürlich totaler Bullshit ist, weil Apple stellt genau für diesen Fall Funktionen zur Verfügung. Aber geht halt nicht, ging halt nicht. Das hat so weit gebracht, dass die wirklich, haben die entnervt aufgegeben sogar?
Wer?
Die von Rogue Amöbier. Die haben gesagt, dass wir in Zukunft einfach keine iPhone-Programme mehr rausbringen.
Ja, ich glaube schon, oder?
Jetzt habe ich erstmal das Problem gelöst. Es war halt so, dass sie das erstmal scheiße fanden, dann öffentlich angeprangert haben.
Dann haben sie da ein wirklich hässliches Eikenstatusen eingebaut, in dem Fall das Safari. Da vorne ist dieses EFS-Eikenstatusen.
Dann ist wieder die ganze Scheiße auf den Upstore geprasselt und bei Apple auch. Sie haben eingesehen, dass das an der Stelle mal wieder so ein typischer Fnord war, von wegen, ja ich meine...
Aber nicht, dass das Thema ist kaputt, sondern natürlich nur ein kleiner Fall.
Sie sind halt bei ihrem IP-Sytze natürlich vorsichtig. Also bei ihrem Intellektual-Propagetie-Schnickes-Roller. Kann ja auch verstehen. Und gerade mit ihrem Logo ist so eine Sache. Da will man natürlich nicht, dass er schändlich... Wie auch immer, ist so. Nur die Interpretation dessen, was jetzt tatsächlich einen Verstoß bewirkt. Du darfst natürlich nicht Apples Logos in deinem Programm einbauen als solche. Dass sie das an der Stelle anzeigen, weil ihnen das API auf dem Mac das gegeben hat, und sie es ja nur weiterreichen, hat halt einfach derjenige, der das bearbeitet hat, an der Stelle auf Basis seiner Vorgaben.
So simpel ist das nämlich gar nicht. Weil zuerst ist das ja mal abgelehnt worden. Und dann sind sie nämlich mit jemanden in Kontakt gekommen bei Apple, der sich von sich aus gemeldet hatte, aus dem App Store und gesagt hat, ich finde euer App echt geil. Und ich mag euch als Firma und ich möchte gerne dieses Programm drauf haben. Schickt das nochmal so und so zu und ich rede nochmal. Ich bringe das mal in das so und so oft stattfindende Meeting ein quasi. Lass uns mal gucken, ob wir das nicht doch hinkriegen. Und der hat sich dann nach einer Weile zurückgemeldet und hat wohl gemeint, da ist nichts zu machen. Probiert es gar nicht erst. Das ist nicht an einem einzelnen kleinen App Store-Monkey gescheitert, der da die ganze Zeit nur blöd da klickt und guckt, ob da ein Safari-Eikon drin ist. Sondern das ist wohl schon ein paar Ebenenhöhe abgeprallt. Also offensichtlich ist das nicht so eine einzelne Person, die da durch tickt, sondern das ist wirklich ein bisschen das App Store Prozedere, das so aussieht. Und womit so dieses Argumente, im Falle von massiver Blödheit, wohl vielleicht einfach, da der einzelne, schlecht angelernte Mitarbeiter nicht ganz das geleistete, was er vielleicht leisten soll, leider ein bisschen schief geht. Gleichzeitig hat ja noch der entsprechende Facebook-Entwickler aufgegeben. Das hast du auch mitbekommen, oder?
Ja, dieser Joe Yult oder so.
Ich weiß nicht mehr, wie er hieß. Auf jeden Fall der Mensch, der das wirklich gute Facebook-App geschrieben hat, hat auch gesagt, ich mach das in Zukunft nicht mehr weiter. Und zwar explizit auch wegen App Store Problematik. Du weißt, die Leute sind echt genervt. Und was ich an der Stelle noch erzählen kann, hast du mitgekriegt, dass das Programm, das App vom Stern, dass das kurzzeitig aus dem App Store rausgenommen worden ist?
Wegen zu viel Titten?
Ja, das hab ich auch gehört.
Und das finde ich mal, das ist so im Zuge, der von das Springer jetzt großartig draufsetzt.
Aber lass mal die Titten mal kurz raus, weil jetzt haben wir nämlich gerade eine wunderbare Vorgabe. Und ich begrüße jetzt hier auf der Leitung, nachdem ich jetzt meinen Mischpult-Setup hier in den Griff bekommen habe, den Dirk.
So, jetzt sag ich auch nochmal Hallo Dirk.
Der heißt Max.
Und immer nur die Stimmen hört.
Genau. Jetzt hab ich dich noch nur auf dem richtigen Kanal. Da muss ich nochmal ein bisschen nachbauen. Aber warum ich jetzt hier gerade versuche, du Dirk Holtwig, du machst derzeit das Wave-Board für den Mac und für das iPhone, also die Applikation, die Google Wave mehr auf den Desktop bringt. Da gibt es ja auch, glaube ich, eine ganze Menge Missverständnisse darüber, was die Applikationen jetzt genau machen. Vielleicht kannst du das ja nochmal mit deinen eigenen Worten beschreiben.
Ja, kann ich gerne machen. Also es gibt zwei Applikationen. Zuerst gab es die iPhone-Applikation und dann habe ich noch eine Mac-Version programmiert. Ja, die habe ich zuerst angefangen, ja. Ich meine schon, ja. Ich hoffe, ich erinnere mich richtig. Ja, und dann habe ich halt die Mac-Version geschrieben. Beides sind im Prinzip Applikationen, die den Browser einfassen. Also sozusagen, es sind specific browsers. Und ja, auf dem iPhone ist es den technischen Umständen geschuldet, dass das relativ einfach alles ist, weil ich hätte gerne mehr Features eingebaut. Das ist aber leider nicht so einfach möglich. Zum Beispiel ich gerne Features eingebaut, wie Bilder hochladen über die Kamera und so weiter. Aber es gibt halt keine richtige API für die Client-Seite des Google Waves. Und dadurch war ich da sehr stark eingeschränkt und habe dann im Prinzip nur einen Browser gehabt, wo ich dann für Externe Links wenigstens einen spezifischen Browser nochmal eingebaut habe, der die Navigation dort vereinfacht und angenehmer macht. Und durch Schütteln kann man sich ausloggen. Das geht sonst nämlich auch nicht. Jeden Knopf haben sie auch vergessen. Nee, ich log dann richtig aus. Also ich rufe dann die URL auf, die da vorgesehen ist. Das ist zufällig die gleiche wie auch auf dem normalen Browser. Und dann ist man halt richtig ausgelockt.
Also kurz gesagt, du versuchst sozusagen mehr von den nativen Features des Rechners, sei es jetzt das iPhone oder ein Mac, da so mit ins Spiel zu bringen, um Wave zu benutzen.
Bei der nächsten Version, die jetzt gerade auch im App Store Review ist, wo ihr gerade wahrscheinlich drüber gesprochen habt, was ich leider nicht genau gehört habe, ist es halt auch so, dass ich da versuche, zum Beispiel den Geschwindigkeitsfaktor zu optimieren, indem ich halt sehr schnell schon mal diese Inbox lade, damit man sehen kann, was hat sich überhaupt geändert. Das geht halt innerhalb von Sekunden, auch über Edge und 3G. Und ja, noch ein anderes Feature ist Push-Notification.
Worüber wir geredet haben, ist halt erstmal dieser Fall von Rok Amöba und Max hat es gerade erwähnt, dass es ja auch mit diesem Joe Yewit heißt er, glaube ich, da so ein Problem gab. Dann hatte ich in deinem Blog gelesen, dass du da auf eine ähnliche Falle gestoßen bist, bei deinem iPhone-Kram, aber mit diesem Framework, vielleicht kannst du mal kurz da den Zusammenhang erklären, was das Problem von dem Facebook-Menschen war und was da da ein Problem ist.
Ja genau, Joe Yewit, der hat die Facebook-Applikation geschrieben und hat sehr viel, sagen wir mal, Grundlagen, Software entwickelt, die er dann zu einem Framework zusammengefasst hat, das sich 320 nennt. Und in dem sind zum Beispiel solche Browser-Komponenten drin oder URL-Loading ist dort drin. Viele weiterführende Widgets und Funktionen, die zum Programmieren nützlich sind, weil man will ja nicht immer alles direkt wieder neu erfinden. Das habe ich unter anderem in dieser Software und auch in anderer Software genutzt. Nun hatte sich bei diesem Framework einige Aufrufe an die private API, so wird das da genannt, Private API, von Apple reingeschlichen, sage ich jetzt mal so. Also da hatte der Joe Hewitt halt was ausprobiert und vergesse wieder rauszunehmen. Und wie der Zufall, dass es so wild hat, jetzt vor einigen Wochen, hat Apple wohl angefangen, mit statischen Code-Analysen herauszufinden, ob dort irgendwelche dieser Aufrufe stattfinden. Und wenn das der Fall ist, verstößt man halt gegen die Bedingungen, die man unterschrieben hat als Entwickler bei Apple und das heißt unterschrieben, also bestätigt hat. Und deswegen wird halt schon mal per se eine Applikation abgelehnt. Das betrifft eigentlich schon eine ganze Menge Leute.
Aber was macht denn dieses Re-20-Framework?
Ja, das selber macht nichts Wildes.
Ich meine, was macht das überhaupt? Also was nimmt es einem ab? Warum sollte man das verwenden? Warum hast du das verwendet?
Ich hab's deswegen verwendet, also hauptsächlich setze ich es ein wegen dem URL-Loading. Normalerweise ist das halt unter Mac und iPhone. Geht das zwar auch, aber man muss viel Code drumherum schreiben und er hat sozusagen das mit dem asynchronen Laden von Bildern und so weiter in Tabellen stark vereinfacht. Man möchte ja zum Beispiel bei so einem Twitter-Client oder irgendetwas anderes, dass die Bilder der User so nach und nach nachgeladen werden und damit das da keine Verzögerung gibt. Und da hat er zum Beispiel ziemlich viele Features eingebaut, die das halt wirklich in ein paar Zeilen Code das erledigt ist.
Und was hat er dann eingebaut, woran der sich der App Store mensch-dage oder was, wo diese Applikation angeschlagen hat oder vermutlich diese Applikation angeschlagen hat?
Ja, es gibt halt eine Schnittstelle bei iPhone, die nennt sich UI-Touch. Damit kann man sozusagen die Finger-Applikation, also die Finger-Touches auf dem Screen abfangen und diese Schnittstelle hat er verwendet, um so ein Scroll-Feld neu zu schreiben. So sah es jedenfalls in dem Source-Code aus und da hat er ein paar Aufrufe benutzt, um zum Beispiel die Anzahl der Finger oder sowas irgendwie schneller festzustellen oder so etwas in der Art. Also ich hab's jetzt nicht genau angeguckt, weil ich hab's einfach dann schnell rausgeschmissen, damit meine Applikation auch wieder in den App-Store reinkommt. Aber nach so was sah es halt aus, ja.
Also es war jetzt überhaupt auch nichts Böses oder so, sondern alle haben jetzt so das Problem, dass dieses Check-Tool jetzt da überprüft, ob überhaupt irgendwann mal vielleicht irgendwann ein interner Call gemacht werden könnte und selbst wenn der nie kommt, ist das ein Problem, ne?
Ja, sie prüfen nicht, ob der irgendwann mal aufgerufen wird. Also sie haben da jetzt nicht so ein OS, in dem sie Programma laufen lassen und dass da ein rotes Lämpchen angeht, wenn irgendwas Privates aufgerufen wurde.
Also es ist keine VM, sondern es ist wirklich ein Tool, was sich einfach das Bein renimmt und dadurch pflügt.
Genau, es ist so absurd, dass ein anderes Framework, das heißt ASE, HTTP-Request, das verwendete nur einen Aufruf, der so hieß wie eine private API. Und dann trotzdem, also es hatte gar nichts damit zu tun, mit diesem privaten Aufruf da. Aber ja, es wurde trotzdem deswegen abgelehnt. Und ja, das ist total absurd eigentlich. Und viele benutzen wirklich nicht diese Komponenten, die da verwendet werden. Es gibt noch einen ganz anderen absurden Ansatz dabei, weil bisher hat sich Apple eigentlich nicht richtig daran gestört. Zum Beispiel gibt es nur eine Methode, eine wirklich zuverlässige jetzt in OS 3.0 und folgende, um sozusagen den Bildschirm-Inhalt auszulesen. Die Routine ist auf jeden Fall illegal, nicht dokumentiert. Die wird aber zum Beispiel verwendet von diesen ganzen Barcode-Readern und so weiter. Und ja, da stört sich Apple auch nicht dran. Das ist natürlich ziemlich ärgerlich. Ein Freund von mir zum Beispiel hat eine Applikation geschrieben für Farblinde, die halt die Unterscheidung zwischen Rot und Grün macht, über das Kamerabild. Hat diese Sache verwendet, ist auch in den App-Store reingekommen. Und ja, hat er dann natürlich ein Update machen wollen, um noch neue Features einzubauen und so weiter. Und das ist aus dem gleichen Grunde auch abgelehnt worden.
Ich hab mich nämlich immer gefragt, wie diese Barcode-Programme das eigentlich machen. Weil es gibt keine API, um die Live-Kamera abzufragen, sondern es gibt nur, man kann ein Bild machen, und dann kann man nachhinein von diesem Bild dann irgendwie das...
Genau, und das Bild machen, das dauert halt relativ lange.
Na, und bei einer Barcode-App ist es natürlich schöner, wenn man sieht, er hat es erkannt und nicht 100-mal Fotos machen müssen, bis, ah ja, jetzt hat er wirklich den Barcode erkannt.
Jetzt haben wir auch den Teilnehmer irgendwie nicht mehr erkannt, weil die Skype-Verbindung ist hier gerade weggegangen. Ich rufe gleich mal an, gutes Zeichen. Wir hören ja auch gleich schon das Piep-Piep. Ich weiß nicht so ganz genau, was das Problem ist. Ich hoffe nicht, dass hier unser ganzes Internet braun ist, aber hier wird eigentlich ganz fleißig irgendwie hoch und runter geladen, oder?
Ja, ich glaube, das funktioniert alles. Alle meine Tore entlaufen.
Nee, Internet ist heute ausnahmsweise mal nicht das Problem. Ich kann euch nicht hören, sagt er. Ja, Verbindung ist irgendwie weg. Reden wir gleich mal mit ihm weiter. Also das ist natürlich ein echtes Problem. Ich werde mal hier mal meinen Skype neu starten. Vielleicht hilft das ja auch.
Wobei ich diesen statischen Code-Check, rein von der Logik her, das erste Mal finde, dass das ist ja ein Teil, den ich noch am ehesten nachvollziehen kann. Zum einen gab es ja mal diese lustigen Skandale, dass irgendwelche Programme wild deine Telefonnummer durch die Gegend gepustet haben und die an irgendwelche Server geschickt haben, was ich nicht unbedingt möchte, dass ein Programm meine Telefonnummer rumschickt. Und dass trotz dieses harten Review-Prozesses solche Sachen bisher noch nicht gecheckt worden, finde ich ehrlich gesagt relativ schlampig. Also das finde ich mal, wenn der API verboten ist.
So, vielleicht lassen wir mal das Video hier weg parallel.
Genau.
Keine Ahnung, ob das jetzt der Grund war, dass du einfach weggeflogen bist, ohne dass jetzt hier nennenswert mein Internet tot gewesen wäre.
Wir haben uns auch weiterhin gesehen. Dein Flag war grün.
Jaja, dieses Internet ist eine gründliche Wahl.
Ja, ja, furchtbar wird man das verbieten.
Wir waren dabei, dass einfach dieses Tool, was halt jetzt irgendwie statisch im Code rummacht, irgendwie an sich ein heeres Ziel hat, aber natürlich dann so ein bisschen den Punkt nicht trifft, weil es halt nicht unterscheidet zwischen wirklich das Potenzial haben, etwas aufzurufen, was so heißt wie etwas Privates und das dann auch tatsächlich tun. Und das ist ja auch an einer anderen Stelle ein Problem gewesen, zum Beispiel, wo ein Programm halt explizit die Versionsnummer des OS testet und unter 3.1 etwas aufruft, was halt offiziell war, da ging es auch irgendwie um die Kamera, ich weiß es nicht mehr ganz genau, und unter 3.0, wo das noch nicht offiziell war, das eben noch nicht tut. Und also ein vollkultimes Verhalten an den Tag legt, aber auch das ein Opfer dieses Tools wird. Ich meine, gut, das ist wie bei allem, das sind sicherlich Dinge, die Apple auch mittelfristig zur Kenntnis nimmt, aber es ist ja ganz offensichtlich so, es gibt einfach Ärger. Was ich persönlich am besten gleich nachvollziehen kann bei dieser ganzen Sache ist, man hat einfach so wenig Kontrolle, also Kontrolle ist vielleicht nicht das richtige Wort, aber auch so wenig Kontakt zu diesem Prozess als Entwickler, und es gibt so viele, oder zumindest gibt es so viele öffentlich bekannte Fälle, die einem immer wieder dieses Gefühl geben, ob jetzt ein Update meiner Software jemals das Licht des Tages erblicken wird und etwas verbessern wird, was unter Umständen gerade ganz schlimm ist, das steht irgendwie auf wackeligen Beinen.
Man weiß nicht, was da bei Apple vor sich geht. Ich bin ja schon seit über einem Jahr irgendwie, ärgere ich mich über diesen ganzen Prozess, und meine erste Applikation wurde wegen mangelnder Nützlichkeit abgelehnt. Es war so ein Phone-Gap-Browser, mit dem man per JavaScript an die Kamera benutzen konnte. Mangelnder Nützlichkeit, das ist ja auch geil. Es ist auch, wenn man sich den ganzen Text bei denen mal durchliest, sie können auch willkürlich ablehnen. Sie brauchen auch keine Begründung zu geben. Sie geben auch oft auch keine. Mittlerweile rufen sie auch persönlich mal irgendwo an. Das hab ich auch schon mitgekriegt von anderen Entwicklern, dass die sich da mal persönlich melden. Aber wenn man dann zurückruft, erreicht man die Nummer trotzdem nicht. Ich hab auch gehört, dass offensichtlich teilweise die Software auch in Deutschland getestet wird. Das ist mir persönlich noch nie passiert.
Ich meine, dass ja auch in Deutschland Leute anrufen?
Jaja, oder nach amerikanischer Zeit offensichtlich. Wenn man Apple anruft, muss man da springen. Ja, es ist ziemlich interessant. Ich persönlich finde das wirklich sehr unangenehm. Für mich grenzt das schon fast irgendwie an Zensur. Das ist mein persönliches Empfinden. Ich denke, das sieht jeder anders. Aber für mich ist das so. Ich sehe keinen technischen Grund darin, dass man das verbieten sollte. Was kann man schon in dieser Sandbox, in der man da auf dem iPhone ist, anrichten? Und wenn es um die Inhalte geht, dazu haben sie doch jetzt diese ganzen Markierungen eingeführt nach dem Motto sexueller Inhalt, Gewalt und so weiter. Wofür haben sie es gemacht, wenn sie es nicht nutzen wollen?
Man könnte ja auch noch andere Flex einführen, so wie das Programm ist nutzlos oder tut.
Dieses Programm greift aufs Internet zu und kann darum theoretisch in irgendeiner Form...
Das kannst du ja anklicken, aber auch so Sachen, die sie sonst so vermengeln.
Dass du es aufs Internet zugreifen kannst? Nö, da musst du ab 17 plus machen.
Du musst die Konsequenz anklicken, nicht den Grund.
Was ich auch komisch finde, sind Dinge, die wirklich schadhaft sind, wie zum Beispiel Zugriff auf das Adressbuch, das nicht weiter kontrolliert wird. Da kümmert sich kein Mensch drum.
Ach, der wird nach wie vor nicht kontrolliert?
Ja, mir ist das mittlerweile nicht untergekommen.
Ich weiß, dass viele Programme die Telefonnummer übertragen haben und dass das wohl als eine Private App gilt.
Ich glaube nicht, dass du die eigene Telefonnummer ausfinden kannst, aber du kannst doch eigentlich...
Doch, doch, die eigene Telefonnummer konntest du bisher auch rausfinden und verschicken. Das ist eine Private App. Das kenne ich ja nicht. Und das ist der Grund, warum ich das wieder ganz okay finde, dass wenn ein Programm schon vier Monate in einem Review-Prozess gehangen hat, wenigstens meine Telefonnummer sicher nicht übertragen wird.
Ja, natürlich, absolut, da bin ich auch ganz deiner Meinung. Aber das kann man auch auf technischer Ebene abfangen. Man muss ja diese Befehle nicht da freigeben für Entwickler. Also so auch, dass sie wirklich benutzt werden können und aufgerufen werden können. Ich denke, dass das technisch durchaus irgendwie machbar ist. Ja, ich meine, wenn man eine Sandbox herstellen kann, dann kann man solche Dinge sicherlich auch entfernen. Na, ich bin schon ziemlich abgeschreckt. Ich habe also mein Verhalten geändert, in dem Sinne, dass ich mir absolut bewusst bin, dass ich nicht viel Zeit investiere in ein Programm, was eventuell dann einfach nicht zugelassen wird. Und das kann jedes Programm sein. Es macht einfach keinen Sinn, sagen wir mal, Zeit investieren in ein Projekt fürs iPhone schon gar nicht gegenüber einem Kunden, zum Beispiel, wenn man jetzt so etwas an einem Kunden anbieten wollen würde, weil man hat keinerlei Gewährleistung, keinerlei Kriterien. Das ist absolut willkürlich. Sie ändern ja offensichtlich zwischendurch ohne Ankündigung auch ihre Testverfahren und so. Ja, aber es bleibt einem im Moment nicht viel anderes über, weil es einfach die populärste Plattform ist. Und du da, sagen wir mal, auf dem mobilen Markt noch im Moment, das ziemlich erfolgversprechend ist, so in diesem Sinne.
Das mit Kunden, das ist ein interessanter Punkt, da habe ich noch gar nicht drüber nachgedacht. Das ist ja auch klar, wenn man als Auftragsarbeit...
Boah, das möchte ich aber nicht gegen einen Kunden im Nacken sitzen haben.
Ja, vor allem, wenn der sich dann einfach quer stellt. Ich meine, Vertrag hin, Vertrag her. Im Prinzip muss er halt von vornherein sagen, ich kann zwar jetzt was für Sie machen, aber es kann sein, dass es nie das Licht des Tages erblickt und es ist dann nicht meine Schuld. Aber das werden Sie ja mehr nicht glauben.
Also schon allein, also ich meine, muss ja nicht mal das sein. Allein der Review-Prozess, ich habe eine Date bis dann, dann sollte das sein. Ich werde einen Monat vorher fertig mit dem App, lade das vielleicht mit ein und dann lässt sich Apple einfach hängen. Du hast echt den...
Ja, aber das ist genau, das ist die Realität. Ich habe auch ein Projekt geschrieben, das heißt Movio, da habe ich auch gerade von Videos und Twitter gesprochen, das ist auch so ein Projekt, also mov.io. Da habe ich den Twitter-Client für geschrieben und er ist auch jetzt durch diese ganzen Querelen, jetzt hat dieser Client immer noch nicht das Licht des Tages erblickt. Und das ist natürlich echt blöd, weil die Online-Plattform ist halt ein Monat online. Und wir sind alle ziemlich genervt deswegen, weil es einfach da nicht vorangeht, weil Apple das einfach nicht reinstellt in den Store.
Also ich muss ja sagen, ich war ja am Anfang, habe ich da noch irgendwie ein gewisses Verständnis aufgebracht, aber ich frage mich jetzt ernsthaft, wie sie sich da jetzt weiter verhalten können. Ich meine, auf der einen Seite kann man natürlich sagen, kann die da im Arsch vorbei gehen, sie sind die Nummer eins, la la la, der Platze. Und für die allermeisten gibt es ja auch keinen Ärger. Aber was ich ganz interessant, weil du hast ja auch dieses Review, dieses Essay gelesen von Paul Graham.
Wo ich mal überflogen kann.
Das ist ja ein sehr kluger Kopf und der sagt ja immer wieder interessante Dinge. Und seine Kernthese, nicht, dass ich jetzt mal so grob zusammenstampfen darf, was er länglich ausgeführt hat, war, das Problem ist eigentlich, dass man einfach das Vertrauen der Entwickler verliert. Und das ist irgendwie eigentlich der schlimmste Raubbau, den man so betreiben kann. Dass einfach dieses Vertrauen an die Plattform komplett verloren geht und das ist auch das, was sie langfristig am meisten schädigen kann.
Ja und das ist total schade, weil die Plattform ist schön. Also es macht auch Spaß dafür zu programmieren. Es ist nur so leidig, weil du immer sozusagen Apple da als vielkürlichen Faktor dazwischen hast. Und diese Bevormundung, ich meine, wir sind alle erwachsene Menschen, hat er schon gerne.
Genau. Ich meine, auf der anderen Seite kann man natürlich verstehen, ihre Motivation ist, ja, ich meine, sie wollen etwas, sie wollen etwas leisten, was unter Umständen nicht zu leisten ist, nämlich die Qualität hochhalten und ihre Kunden beschützen. Immer so ein bisschen wie mit unseren Familienministerinnen, die uns vor irgendwie bösen Inhalten beschützen möchten. Irgendwie kann das nicht packen. Aber die Frage ist, davon ausgehend, dass Apple jetzt ihre Grundlinie, dass sie sozusagen über alles nochmal drüber schauen wollen, dass sie das nicht verlassen. Hast du denn Ideen und Vorschläge, was sie in dem Rahmen tun könnten? Insbesondere, um sowas wie Bugfixes, die dringend sind, durchzulassen und so weiter. Wie man sowas realisieren könnte.
Ich bin eigentlich dafür, dass man diesen Prozess komplett abschafft und stattdessen eher so einen Premiumbereich einführt. Nach dem Motto, wenn du wirklich Lust hast auf total geprüfte Software und irgendwie mit dem Super-Apple-Zertifikat drauf, dann holst du die Sachen nur da. Ich meine, im Prinzip gibt es das jetzt auch schon mit diesen ganzen Jailbreaks und so weiter. Die Leute sind ja gezwungen, sich das Telefon aufzumachen, um an viele Dinge ranzukommen, die sie interessieren. Damit hat Apple sich ja quasi selber irgendwie das Beinchen gestellt. Ich denke, dass viele von den Jailbreakern das nicht machen würden, wenn die entsprechend die Möglichkeit hätten, auch so an ihre Software ranzukommen. Das ist so meine These. Und deswegen würde ich sagen, Apple schafft es lieber ab. Und ja, sage, es gibt irgendwie noch so ein Premium-Bereich, weil alle anderen Dinge können irgendwie nur scheitern. Auch die Sache mit dem schnellen Update, Bugfixes und so weiter, oder Developer, die bekannt dafür sind, guten Cops zu liefern und so weiter. Das will dann wieder jeder sein. Jeder hat eine wichtige Abwirkung. Es wird zum Ungerechtigkeit geben. Wenn man keine gute Regelung finden kann, finde ich, soll man es abschaffen.
Ich habe gerade dieses Sternproblem angesprochen, dass dieses Ab vom Stern entfernt worden ist aus dem App Store. Zwischendurch mal kurzzeitig, nachdem schon zugelassen war.
Weil im Content ihrer Webseite irgendwie Titten waren.
Ich vermute, dass da jetzt auch irgendwie zensiert wird, damit das nicht noch mal passiert. Das ist ja auch nicht im Sinne des Erfinders.
Das muss man echt mal sagen. Das ist der Stern, der es im App Store vertreten. Springer will großspurig ein App Store. Und alle jeden anderen. Und der Spiegel.
Bild verzichtet jetzt für iPhone-Einnahmen auf Titten.
Aber einfach mal diese Vorstellung, dass offensichtlich da tatsächlich bei Apple jemand sich regelmäßig den Content anguckt von irgendwelchen News-Websites und das Programm einfach aus dem App Store rausschmeißt, wenn ihnen das nicht in Kram passt, was da zu sehen ist.
Ja, unglaublich.
Das ist fucking Zensur.
Ja, aber andersherum. Das, was ich auch gerne bringe, ist diese Sache mit meinem Kampf von Hitler. Das hat mich persönlich richtig angekotzt, weil ich finde das wirklich unmöglich. Offensichtlich haben wir es hier auch damit zu tun, dass da gewisse Moralvorstellungen irgendwie von Apple im App Store und im Review-Prozess und den Inhalten abgebildet wird. Aber andererseits wird da auch keine Rücksicht auf Empfindlichkeiten anderer Leute genommen. Ich finde sowas total geschmacklos, abgesehen davon, dass sowieso auch irgendwie strafbar ist.
Das ist einfach ein extrem amerikanischer Prozess. Meinungsfreiheit deckt selbstverständlich das Darstellen von Hakenkreuzen ab, aber sobald eine Brustwarze zu sehen sein könnte, wird es problematisch in Amerika. Ich glaube, das ist einfach amerikanische Moral in Höchstform.
Sie machen, wie sie wollen, aber ich würde schon ganz gerne hier meinen Lifestyle machen.
Ja klar, natürlich. Ich wäre dafür, dass man Hakenkreuze zeigen darf und dafür alles andere auch zeigen darf. Ich bin ja nicht so ein Zensur-Freund in keiner Beziehung.
Du darfst es ja zeigen, aber...
Du willst ja nur deine Bild-Titten sehen.
Ich will ja nur meine Bild-Titten sehen, genau. Überlegt euch mal, wenn plötzlich der Spiegel nicht mehr da ist, weil er auf der Titelseite mal Titten drauf hatte und der dann aus dem App-Store gepullt wird. Deswegen.
Das ist auch schnell mal ein Vorwand.
Das kann beim Spiegel auch durchaus passieren. Das sind anerkannte, seriöse Nachrichtenmagazine.
Das ist haarsträubend eigentlich. Das sollte auch allen Verlegern, ehrlich gesagt, allen Verlegern, die im Augenblick damit liebäugeln, Paid-Content fürs iPhone anzubieten, doch eine Warnung sein.
Vielleicht sollten sie da nochmal irgendwie auch, sie haben ja auch sozusagen eine publizistische Macht, vielleicht gegenüber Apple auch nochmal sagen, hör mal, wir sind interessiert, eure Plattform da was drauf zu tun und ihr werdet davon ja auch profitieren. Ja, aber unter den Umständen geht das irgendwie für uns nicht.
Wie soll das weitergehen, wenn Apple dann anfängt, die gleichen Dinge beim iTunes-Store anzusetzen, die gleichen Maßstäbe, wie sie im Augenblick beim App-Store ansetzen?
Oder die anderen Anbieter, also was passiert, wenn andere sagen, wenn Apple das machen kann, warum soll das nicht auf dem Palm, auf dem Android und so weiter dann auch gehen? Oder was auch immer für alles Mögliche oder auf einem eigenen Computer, auf einem Mac-Betriebssystem. Solche Überlegungen gab es auch früher mal, dass man das irgendwie einschränkt. Wo hört das auf? Ich bin ja kein großer Fan von diesem Ganzen.
Aber jetzt mal, nur mal ganz pragmatisch, weil ja nicht unbedingt davon auszugehen ist, dass sie das jetzt so machen werden mit einem Premium-Store. Ich meine, auch so ein Premium-Store wirft ja wieder neue Fragen auf mit, warum sollte denn überhaupt noch jemand in einen Premium-Store gehen, wenn es dazu führt, dass deine Programme später released werden? Das ist ja irgendwie, aber du meinst wahrscheinlich eher so einen nachträglichen Prozess, dass man sich das sozusagen absegnen lässt, ein Release, wo dann draufsteht, dass es jetzt aber auch mal irgendwie von unseren Hynies begutachtet worden und wir finden das gut.
Ja genau, so bio-bio-mäßig.
Man könnte es ja so machen wie bei Android. Bei Android ist es ja, du hast in diesem Market noch eine ganze Menge drin. Aber auch nicht alles. Und wenn du wirklich alles da drin haben willst, das kannst du ja per Package, was du dir über einen normalen Webbrowser runterlädst, installieren.
jetzt auch alternative Upstores. Ich hab so mit dem einen Auge wahrgenommen, dass irgendjemand dir jetzt so ein Porno, so ein Adult-Application-Store für Android anbieten will.
Oh, jetzt brauch ich ganz dringend installieren.
Was natürlich super ist. Endlich wissen mal die Leute, wo sie irgendwie ihren mobilem Porn-Content kriegen. Das könnte Android echt nach vorne bringen. Das meine ich jetzt auch echt ernst.
Das ist wahrscheinlich der Glück.
Ja, die Amerikaner, die stellen sich da irgendwie auch selber einen Bein. Kann das übrigens sein, dass du in deinem Setup irgendwie deine Audio-Balance ein bisschen durcheinander gebracht hast? Weil ich hab jetzt hier die ganze Zeit geguckt, ob es bei mir liegen kann, aber irgendwie... Ich glaube, jetzt kommst du hier schon links, rechts verschoben rein.
Ich hab hier nur ein Mikrofon, in das ich reinspreche. Ich vermute mal.
Aber es gibt da so auf deinem Macintosh so ein Sound-Control-Feld. Da kann das auch schnell mal verstellt sein.
Ein Sound-Control-Feld? Ja, das werd ich doch direkt mal anschauen.
Neben Sachen, Themen hier.
Es sah grad schon ein bisschen da noch aus, aber...
Ist alles gerade? Dann weiß ich nicht, was das Problem ist. Anyway, müssen wir jetzt auch nicht in der Sendung lösen, das Problem?
So viel hab ich zum App Store zu sagen. Das ist auf jeden Fall... Ich hoffe, dass Apple sich da ändert, also sein Vorgehen ändert, auch den Entwicklern zuliebe, weil, ich meine, nicht ein geringer Teil des Erfolges hängt ja auch davon ab, dass viele Programme fürs iPhone verfügbar sind und irgendjemand musste ihr schreiben. Und deswegen wäre das eigentlich nur nett von Apple, wenn sie uns da ein bisschen entgegenkämen.
Ja, das Statement wollte ich auch mal so drin haben, ein bisschen mit den Betroffenen reden und nicht immer nur über die Betroffenen reden. Nicht immer nur über die Betroffenen herziehen. Okay, Dirk, ich sag mal Tschüss und vielen Dank.
Ja, ich danke euch.
Für den Beitrag, den zweiten Anlauf hat es ja technisch sogar tatsächlich funktioniert. Tschüss nach Duisburg, bis bald. Dieses Skype-Sound ist lustig, ne? Ich mag die irgendwie.
Die sind gar nicht so schlecht, das stimmt. Aber ansonsten ist Skype echt pain in the ass.
Findest du?
Ja, ich find Skype furchtbar.
Was war noch bitte das, was gut funktioniert und wie gut der Audioqualität hat und durch jede Firewall durchkommt?
Das ist Skype, das User Interface ist furchtbar.
Na ja, gut, das lernt man einmal, dann funktioniert es. Ich muss nur auf die gute Taste drücken. Ich fand es echt, als dieser Sound-Dreher herkommt, ich glaub, das war trotzdem bei ihm. Ich glaub das nicht, dass es an mir liegt.
Also was mich bei Skype total stört, erstens ist meine Adressliste regelmäßig mal zu, dann ist dieser Tab, dieser seitlich so rausfährt, wo meine offenen Gesprächsfenster drin sind, regelmäßig zu und den muss man dann mehrfach anklicken, damit er wieder aufgeht. Und dann ist es bei Adium so, wenn mich jemand angechattet hat und ich klicke bei Adium auf das Icon drauf, dann springt er automatisch zu dem Tab der Person, die mich gerade angesprochen hat, sodass ich sofort los tippen kann. Das macht Skype nicht, da kann ich erst gehe auf das Fenster, gehe auf Skype, dann sehe ich dieses Chat-Fenster, aber mit einer total anderen Person, als das, die gerade aktuell ist. Dann ist dieser Tab aus irgendeinem Grund zu, dann muss ich den erst aufmachen, dann mache ich den auf, dann muss ich in der langen Liste rungucken, wer hat mich jetzt gerade angequatscht, anklicken und dann kann ich meine Antwort tippen. Das ist total nervig. Adium ist, was das User in deinem Face angeht, echt unglaublich viel besser als Skype. Das ist ja auch ein Chat-Applikation.
Ich hab jetzt hier noch so ein... Also du hast jetzt hier noch was notiert mit irgendwie iPhone kaufen in Frankreich.
Genau.
Wir müssen auch jetzt nämlich langsam mal zum Ende kommen. Ich überleg gerade, ob ich hier irgendwie meine letzten Punkte, ob wir das in die nächste Sendung verschieben.
Die Navigation hätte ich schon gerne.
Über Pirate Bay wollte ich sowieso mit Dennis reden. Der ist jetzt irgendwie nicht da.
Ich wollte einfach mal nachfragen. Hattet ihr mal schon Erfahrungen mit iPhone Kauf in Frankreich? Ich frage für meine Freundin, die fährt nämlich im Weihnachten nach.
Was heißt denn das in Frankreich? Na, da kannst du das Telefon irgendwie teuer anlockt kaufen für mehr Geld. Ich weiß nicht, wie teuer.
Da gibt es ja jetzt eine neue Gesetzgebung, dass es zu den gleichen Konditionen anlockt verkauft werden muss, wie gelockt. Ist das so? Ich weiß auch nichts genaueres.
Wie fährt sie denn nach Frankreich? Mit dem Auto?
Sie fährt gar nicht nach Frankreich, sondern in die niederfranzösischen Grenze.
Dann soll sie nach Belgien gehen.
Naja, das ist südlich, ist ja unten bei Freiburg.
Ah, wir müssen nach Italien fahren.
Ich hab gehört, dass mittlerweile auch in Frankreich problemlos anlockte iPhones gehen. Keine Ahnung. Wäre schön, wenn ihr... Genau, darum bitte ich einfach.
Oh man, jetzt sind wir schon fast eine Stunde über der Zeit, die ich eigentlich so dafür vorhatte. Deswegen würde ich die letzten Punkte dann doch in die nächste Sendung verschieben. Meine Top 10 iPhone-Anoiances.
Ah, das wär eigentlich das...
Hab ich jetzt über Monate gesammelt und...
Du willst jetzt nicht so verbraten auf den letzten Meter, verstehe ich.
Nee, weil jetzt bin ich A, müde, B, wollte ich schon von einer Stunde fertig sein, C, bin ich frustriert, weil ich hier schon wieder an meinem Audio-Setup in letzter Minute rumruckeln musste. Weiß der Guy, ob das hier alles richtig aufgenommen hat, aber ich hab Backup-Recording, das hat funktioniert. Und ohne Dennis mag ich jetzt sowieso nicht mehr. Aber ich fand, dass wir das jetzt ganz gut gemacht haben.
Dafür, dass wir hier nur zu zweit waren, haben wir echt drei Stunden durchgehalten haben. Wow, und sie sind wie im Flugvergang, das hat echt Spaß gemacht.
Es ist nämlich gar nicht so schlecht, sich vorzubereiten, es ist auch überhaupt nicht schlecht, konzentriert bei der Sache zu bleiben.
Wieso guckst du aber so in meine Richtung? Ach, weil niemand andere von mir da ist.
Aufgeräumt hier und aufgekissen.
Genau, wir schalten dem Podcast noch einen Podcast-Store irgendwie mit Improvil vor.
Dann wird jeder Kommentar vorher geprüft und wie gegen Startschritte und Checker gegenlaufen gelassen.
Diese Sendung ist nämlich schon vor zwei Wochen aufgenommen worden und wurde jetzt live ausgestrahlt, nachdem sie Apples Approval bekommen hat.
Was wir aber im Hintergrund nicht bemerkt haben, dass ihr euch eure Telefonnummer hochgeladen habt.
Genau.
Tja, ich bin durch.
Wir sind durch.
Und mehr als eine Stunde kann ich nicht überziehen. Ja, komm. Dann bedanken wir uns hier beim Chat. Jetzt muss ich glaube ich noch Stopp irgendwie sagen. Nee, das könnt ihr selber machen. Und ich habe jetzt ein paar Kapitelmarken hier selber gesetzt und mal schauen. Ich denke, ich werde mal, ja, ich habe da so einen Plan. Und jetzt können wir uns aber erstmal hier verabschieden aus der Sendung und Tschüss sagen. Dann sagen wir dem Chat noch ein bisschen was, der weiß nämlich noch mehr.